what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame
[Applause]
start do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and bring that notification Bell
that we are going to be notified of my
daily videos like the video on your way
in and as you already know if you have
watched two or more of my lives and you
do not subscribe we have beef okay beef
people a couple announcements before we
start the show the first is that we have
two clips channels just pearly clips and
pearl daily make sure you go subscribe
to both of them
the second announcement is that we have
four membership tiers the first tier
gets you to be a part of the live chat
the second tier you get to see our
behind this behind the scenes Vlogs and
our Discord if you want to see me
freestyle rap sign up for the second
um tier third tier you get to connect
with me on social media and the fourth
tier you get a one-on-one call with me
once a month how do you get a million
subscribers in a year do you want to
know sign up for the fourth tier
um also guys they banned my first
Instagram so make sure you go sign up
for my second Instagram or follow my
second Instagram just pearly things one
um we're also on Rumble now we had
um two panels last week and in a
one-on-one interview with Nick Fuentes
that really we're not YouTube friendly
so if you want to go see the full
versions of both of those go on to
rumble now the link to that should be in
the description also guys
um we're trying to get to 20 000
subscribers on the wife School Channel
we're having a new episode where I learn
how to knead bread so if you want to go
see that make sure you go subscribe we
also also have a new animation Channel
just pearly animation so go um it's just
an animated version of our Clips
basically but it's pretty cool this guy
does this whole cartoon thing so it's
it's nice
um we also only have one official uh
pregame page on Instagram and for a
thousand likes today we will open up the
live chat to non-members
and also I'm on Twitter now I'm almost
to 100 000 on Twitter so go follow my
Twitter it's pearlythings with a z at
the end so
um I've been tweeting a lot this week
I'm getting pretty good at it so you
know go follow me on there so today we
have a lovely panel uh welcome to the
show guys thank you
um why don't we go around everyone say
your name your age
um your relationship status fun fact
about yourself and your favorite animal
um my name is Whitney I'm 26 oh my God
for my age I'm 26 and I'm in a
relationship favorite animal is dog
fun thing about myself
we could be here all day if I try and
think of something
um if you have a hobby
not really you know it's not a good
start what are you what do you do in
your free time is it your favorite app
you use tick tock all right I'm a tech
talk fanatic you could say so that would
be it okay your favorite did you say
your favorite animal dog dog all right
if you have a kind of dog
um American bullies
my name is Stephanie I'm 23. I don't
really have a favorite animal
um and a fun fact about me is that I'm
just really random
yeah okay hi guys my name's star
McKenzie I'm 38 and my favorite animal
is a tiger and a fun fact about me is
that I'm an Eclectic Bean so I'll never
look the same whenever you see me you're
a what eclectic being
eclectic many sides
okay I don't know what that means okay
eclectic babe
like you're gonna change
I just evolved with the with the time
yeah I changed my looks obviously my
Persona there's a few but you know it's
in the range this sounds like multiple
personalities that's that too yeah oh
it's the same thing yeah yeah okay okay
uh Auntie go ahead
hi um
I like dogs I like my dogs
do you like my dog no she likes me
so yeah I like Ellie we have an
understanding yeah
so
um so today's topic all right so I have
been tweeting this week or I've been
tweeting a Twitter storm and I tweeted
okay something that got me some backlash
now I felt like I was just calling water
wet but apparently this is offensive in
2023 so I want to know if you guys find
this offensive I said
I said strippers are [__] okay
okay so is that offensive yes or no and
is it true yes or no
offensive yes true no it's not true I
don't think strippers are not hoarse I
don't think so okay yeah I don't think
so Eva but it's offensive it's a you
don't think it's true I don't think it's
true
I don't think it's true and I suppose it
can be offensive depends who's so
strippers are not hoarse I don't think
so no okay
I don't think it's all true and I think
it's only offensive if you're even a
horror stripper
tell me why is it not true
because to me a horror is someone that's
promiscuous right so to me what's more
promiscuous than taking off your clothes
for money then you could say any person
that post is a bikini pic on Instagram
as a whole yeah I would say that too but
I mean my definition of a [__] is if
you're having sex with multiple people
throughout a short period of time
consistently I would call you a hoe I
would put them in that category too oh
yeah 100 they're at the top of the
category for me but if you decide to go
in if you want to be up and down a pole
and make money for it but you're not
sleeping with anyone to me that's not
her because you could sleep with two
people in your lifetime I'd be throwing
it back for money I don't think that
makes you a hoe do you think the
majority of women that are taking off
their clothes for money are super
selective with who they sleep with
um in general not not I know there's
exceptions but in general
probably not however there are there is
the exception but but as a general
statement it's kind of true
I don't know I still I still don't think
he's true personally I don't know no
okay why am I wrong
I just feel like calling strippers I
don't know it's like like she said I
feel like they could be quite selected
for who they're sleeping with they're
not necessarily hoes because just
because they're throwing a back for
money doesn't mean that they're out
there sleeping with multiple men and we
don't know their circumstances like we
don't know why they're stripper they
have their reasons if you're a robber
but you have your reasons for being a
robber it doesn't make you not a robber
okay you got me there
um
it still makes you a rubber because you
stole at the end of the day but
stripping is just it's different it's
like
is promiscuous yes or no no no you don't
think taking off your clothes for money
and putting your boobs in a stranger's
face is promiscuous I mean that's not
not at all I mean shaking ass in like a
stranger okay any man can pay 50
and your boobs are in there in their
face it's not a little okay it depends I
feel like it that's an extensive
stripping like there's some that are
fully undressed and then there's the
ones that you know cover a little bit so
I think I think there's a certain level
to it right well but we're talking about
in general not not there's except you
know there's the I'm sure there's a
virgin stripper out there yeah that's
that's what I'm saying so I don't think
they're necessarily hurts like their
virgin strippers so I promise case
would you say they're more promiscuous
yeah than the average girl sitting on my
couch would you say you're equally as
promiscuous as a stripper the thing is
you can't tell because because
like a triple like you you can't tell
you just can't tell like I could see
someone on the train fully clothed and
in like on underneath she could be
sleeping with like 50 men wear as a
stripper like just because she's naked
or like you know okay so if one guy's a
pickpocketer right and there's another
guy that robs banks for a living right
does that make the make the first guy
not a pickpocketer
like just because there's someone that's
a worse robber than him like aren't they
still all robbers
you know just because one's worse one's
about you know one's Robin Banks right
he could be Robin Banks
but he's just pickpocket and he's not
he's not putting a gun out I
don't know I honestly can't say I just
feel like calling strippers like more
promiscuous than others it's just a bit
much okay is it true it's not true it's
not true not even a little true
no okay all right okay
um I think that the word [__] comes
from back in the days when it's like
another word for prostitute so if a
woman's selling her body for money yeah
she's a [__] but these strippers so we
agree with sex yeah I agree with you
um but these strippers are not having
sex they are 100 promiscuous like
there's no way you can get go from that
you know they're trying to promote sex
sexuality she's shaking her head I think
it's promiscuous I think that her whole
thing is cut I can't lie worth fifty
dollars yes
but realistically you could be on a
train with someone and they could have
taken wood that morning but their
dresses
no but I could if you could have someone
that's a stripper and she's tripping to
get through night school if she's got 50
boobs Fair pages of having good boobs
you can profit off it that doesn't make
you promiscuous though what does
promiscuous mean
promiscuous I mean you don't know what
promiscuous means it's the taking off of
the clothes
like you know strippers I wouldn't say
it's only sex sexual yeah energy
attention feelings thoughts
I mean there's nothing wrong with it
they're they're holding their hands up
say yeah this is what I'm doing for
money they're not sleeping with guys
there's nothing wrong being promiscuous
we are sexual beings as humans so I'm
saying some people have different levels
so it's not a bad thing that shippers
are promiscuous that's what like
um thing that they're in what field
they're in sex would you since they're
not promiscuous would you be okay with
your boyfriends going to a strip club
every day but they're not promiscuous
don't worry yeah because I'll be going
to one too you'd be okay
you know I honestly would not be okay
why not it's just they're like nuns in
there no they're not I'm not saying
they're nuns I'm just saying they have
their reasons it's like the average like
I mean it's the same as the girl on the
train no I just feel like certain
strippers have their reasons for what
they're doing like that could be the
only source of income or they could have
set in circumstances as to what they're
why they're doing so but personally like
I would not want my boyfriend to go to a
strip club I
but the reasons like it still doesn't
take away from the fact that they're
doing what they're doing because
remember a guy could be homeless right
he but he doesn't have the option to go
down to the strip club and get a job he
just has to go get a real job at Subway
the stripper could do that
she just chooses not to she wants easy
money
she might enjoy it yeah yeah that's a
horse like easy money for their bodies
I mean yeah 100 however they might is
you can't say that no one likes Easy
Money everyone wants to make money in an
easy fashion if someone could say if
someone gave you an opportunity not
necessarily to be promiscuous but
another another opportunity that was
quite respectable and it was easy money
you would take it because everyone wants
to make money easily the fact that these
in these individuals decide do you know
what I'm gonna be naked because it's
easier fair play at it I mean I could I
could sell drugs for easy money you know
but it's like at what cost right and
everyone's got a moral framework and I
would say definitely when it comes to
their bodies [__] care less about
selling them
so
is I don't I don't see it as selling
though necessarily I for me what are the
men paying for
for the visual of what it is
like this isn't water wet like guys you
guys know I'm right
she she's she's based a little bit yeah
no I actually know it is because
obviously we're not disputing why
they're doing it you know people
sacrifice whatever it is what it is what
I'm saying they're selling their bodies
you know for money for sexual these guys
are getting sexual pleasure out of it
they're not like dancing to make these
men think about oh yeah I'm gonna go to
the bank do this my job like it's a
thrill it's an excitement I mean it is
what it is there is nothing wrong with
it sex is like the biggest industry I
think after is it before or after it
one of them hmm
it's really after I T is bigger than the
second one I'm surprised it's not sex
first yeah it's one of them what is
between those two Auntie what do you
think um are strippers [__]
yes or no I'm still with the fifth was
it five fifties on the boobs yeah like
you just they pay 50 but I don't know
what they cost you know when you said
that let me know in the chat guys how
much did you pay for your last lap dance
I don't know the real cost I was just
fully quit yeah just say something
totally up subject
once you said that you've got a
fantastic pair of boobs thank you
are wearing a decent bra you have to
there's no spillage I love that when you
said 50
all I saw was her boobs I just think
took up my glasses and my eyes still
were going there I couldn't help it
because she got fantastic yeah I love
that so yeah must be nice um
but I personally think that um they are
selling
they said in six no matter how but
I I know some that um
that go there with their man's blessing
because to them it's just a way of just
going and getting some money let us go
and take it off and do whatever some
people really get into it so some people
it's like clocking in clocking out
but it's still in the sex industry and
that's what's selling
so yeah so yeah they are horse
I think the ones that sleep with men are
[__] and the ones that don't yeah
they're just selling sex I agree so
you've got strippers and you've got
stripper holes you don't think you don't
think it's a [__] if you're literally
being paid to take off your your bra and
put them in random men's face
to me that's
if you if you that's what I said there's
some of them are a [__] those ones are
horse but you've got some that just
don't come off the pond and don't come
off the stage yeah some some people do
that just because they some women find
it empowering
believe it or not
but it's all in the sex interesting it's
all said in sex so so yeah sex sellers
so at the end of the day what's it
what's a sex seller guys what's a sex
seller
or
um this okay so this tweet got so many
views okay I even got the attention of I
was so excited I got the attention of um
Logan Paul's friend I'm trying to find
the Tweet I've been tweeting so much
this week yeah but he dated Lana Rhodes
you know what I'm talking about
Mike something you know what I'm talking
about blessing yeah Mike something and
he tweeted back at me calling me a [__]
back I was like oh how much did you
charge him
thank you
on the podcast let's do it so open
invite to Mike um I don't know your last
name I just know you as Logan Paul's
friend
um anyways
speaking of Horrors famous [__]
who is the most famous horror that you
can think of go Kim Kardashian good one
go
yeah Kim Kardashian kind of a different
one I say Amber Rose Amber Rose
different one
what's her name
can I say you can call this your sister
[Laughter]
I can't think of anyone you just say
Kardashians in general yeah Kardashians
okay I was hoping for a different one
but okay go ahead and
um I'm old school so I'm gonna say
Dita Fontes
I don't know who that is exactly okay
you know who I think of that Hillary
Monica Lewinsky
that's the most famous horror of all
time you know she was in the knees in it
yeah yeah she she made a book out of it
but she didn't actually have sex though
did she that's what she said then what
was it you said his famous words he's
famous with us I did not have sexual
relationships with that woman Auntie she
has sexy relationships with him that's
what you meant
you think they didn't have sex
maybe he just they just went to Second
yeah
he's giving head second base Third Base
I don't know
someone said Larissa Pippin in the chat
okay so
now that we have agreed that I'm right
thank you guys
um
strippers or [__]
um oh actually one more only fans models
are they [__] yes or no
when you say models as in their content
as well yes just themselves like if you
were to say the average only fans model
[__] yes or no no no
Yeah Yeah from the definition like we're
talking yes yes from what it says that
I've never seen it only fans but I'd say
yeah and it's the same as stripping but
on online pretty much but you can you
can just like basically take a nude and
send it to someone or use toys
but again it's completely virtual you're
not you're not doing anything with
someone else so you could be a virgin
isn't it some of it is porn yeah but
some porn stars are husband and wife so
how how many bodies does it take for a
girl to become a [__] I don't think is
the body count I think it's the
frequency the okay how frequent so any
multiple guys in a year how many how
many till [__] and how long is she a
[__] for can she ever
yeah 100 okay so in a year how many
bodies till she is officially [__] I
just think we should nail it down
I think if you have sex with more than
one guy a week that's different
you're a [__] I thought you were going
to say a year
I was like for a year for a week so no
more than no more than
I'd say you should no more than really
ten no more than 10 in a year yeah okay
okay so if she has more if she has 11 in
a year [__] yeah I draw the line at 11.
horror okay what about what about the
next year she has zero was she still a
[__] she's she's rejuvenated
she's a born-again [__] definitely okay
what about what about how many in a year
uh I feel like it's hard to put a number
in it but I don't know yeah like 10 to
think 10 in a year yeah like I don't
know
if you stop being sexually active and
like completely and you don't sleep with
anyone then yeah
not really a [__] anymore yeah born
again all right what about you what
about you how many in a year I say more
than three personally more than three in
a year yeah all right you can't undo
being a [__] definitely I mean you
can't or you can't you can't yeah energy
yeah you can undo it passes the past
yeah not to men unfortunately yeah
you're a [__] forever yeah and if you
ask the guys I'm telling you ask a guy
the same question also they'd be like
10. I thought they meant that for a
lifetime all right that's why I thought
when they said 10 I'm thinking that's
one a month of two months to recover
that's I I look so and two I I think
Asia has more than two but if you can be
a
born again [__] I want to be a virgin
[Laughter]
do you know what I mean that's not C8
works
okay so I have I have some stats for you
guys some fun fun stuff okay here it is
all right according to a 2017 survey
conducted by the Center for Disease
Control and prevention the average
number of sexual partners in American
adults reported having in their lifetime
or in the UK but usually the numbers are
similar how how many average Partners do
you think the average woman has in her
lifetime guess on average yeah according
to the CDC
say 30.
7 this is nothing to do with me guys
it's not my numbers but I think
50 50. I don't say five on average in a
lifetime yeah
you're the Accord according to to what
the women say which let's be honest
4.2 wow that's good that's good so
that's the point two of a person well I
think it's the average so if you know in
a lifetime 4.2 yes is that the new gen
or the object why is it worth 2017
2017. yeah no I don't think they should
them stats are not good they should come
ask people today because I think black
cultures change people say much more
Freer with sexual partners and stuff
what what's changed what do you think
like I think that women are a lot more
free-minded with having sex with random
guys and multiple guys like it's okay
for them to sleep with more people where
obviously back in the day like 2017
sleeping with one one man was enough so
yeah I think those stats they don't they
don't count anymore or would you mean
multiple guys you said random or
multiple yeah like more than one guy
like at the same time some I don't know
no because when you said random you can
have loads of random when she said
multiple
these people just literally linking
people to have sex so you're thinking
well it must be about 15 is that average
now I said 50 babe 50 yeah like from
what I see from the culture and how
people move in I really do think that
that's more of a realistic number yeah
so let's let's do some math here okay so
the average the average age of first
marriage in the UK is 31. okay how long
do you think someone would date before
they get married like two years would
you guess yeah two to four years two to
four years so let's say she meets so 30
29 28 12 I'd say at 27 off the market
with the same guy
how many bodies did she get up to 27
would you say guess
average girl in the UK living in London
let's say London because London's going
to be different than like the other side
of England to average hour I'd say maybe
12. 12. but before didn't you say the
average number was 30 now I'm talking
based on today's statistics of a 27 year
old in London I feel like it's down to
12. I feel like by 27 she could have on
average I'm trying to even it out like
12 12. an average 20 to 27 I'd say like
five six five six yeah Thirty Thirty
Thirty Auntie what do you think
[Laughter]
when she comes out of high school she
would have had 20 by the time she does
this but I just finished College he's
not surprised and uni students it's like
an old yet there isn't it
yeah so why are we so hesitant to call
okay so
I don't have him in front of me so I'm
gonna be butchering this but if you're a
virgin on your wedding night and this to
be fair the stat is from a more Catholic
organization so you can take with a
grain of salt but if you're a virgin on
your wedding night what do you think
your chance of a happy marriage is
um
I think a lot less than if he was to
have sex prior to marriage a lot a lot
you're less likely to be happy if you're
a virgin yeah okay why do you think that
because a lot of other a relationship is
sexual compatibility now I speaking on
myself I've been in situations where
you've not you've prolonged sex with
someone had sex with them and now
everything's just not good anymore no I
don't want to see you anymore because
there's no compatibility you have to you
have to know and understand a person
sexually before you can commit to them
for the rest of your life how did how
did you know how would you know they're
bad if you've never been with anyone
else because you know you know what
feels good enough and what doesn't feel
good and when you were a virgin did you
you did you feel like the person you
were like the first person you had sex
with was bad
no looking back on it now he did all
right to be fair yeah okay okay so what
about you first virgin well you didn't
say a percentage what percentage
um what percent of that you wouldn't be
happy no would be like what percent have
happy marriages of virgins on their
wedding night
say about 25 25 okay I don't know for me
I just feel like you can't base your
happiness and marriage just based on the
sex though no so they take they take you
know how many partners did you have
before marriage they fill out the survey
and then they say are you happily
married after 10 years so it's like what
percent of a hundred women are happy
after 10 years that are virgins on their
wedding night
yeah like again I just don't do you
agree do you do you think virginity has
any impact on the happiness of a
marriage no I don't you don't so it
doesn't matter if you've had a lot or a
little yeah could have what about a
hundred Partners okay 100 Partners
that's yeah okay that could definitely
affect your happiness and marriage but
if you're a virgin I don't see how it
would necessarily affect your happiness
because you don't necessarily know how
it feels okay what do you think I think
like more like 80
um because it's sacred and I think that
the man the husband would cherish his
wife a lot more
um and they grow together they learn
together and usually if you're married
as a virgin you're young you know what I
mean so if they're not going to be happy
in the relationships not because of the
sex it's the emotional and mental thing
but yeah I think they'll be a lot more
happier I'll get married as a virgin
okay Auntie I think you'll be high as
well because you've got nothing to
compare it with and you know you can't
say he's rubbish because you don't know
how rubbish he is you just think that's
it so again this is from a more Catholic
organization so you can take it with a
grain of salt but 80 chance of a happy
marriage if you're a virgin on your
wedding day
I got you know there's free drinks it
off thank you yeah man
um so where
when do you think it changes so what
number of Partners do you think a girl
goes from typically being happy to being
unhappy
unhappy in what sense
um so again they say how many partners
did you have before marriage she says
two three four five ten twenty where do
you where do you see the number changing
um a lot basically I actually saw
something and it said that if you've
slept with more than 25 people by the
time you get married you have a higher
chance of divorce I don't know how
factual that is but um
okay so you think 25 roughly okay what
do you think
I'm trying to think
um
I'll say you in like 10 10 okay
yeah I'll say like 30 I think obviously
it affects the man and his ego and
which is not a bad thing do you know
what I'm saying he emotionally treat her
a certain way and always have this like
hangover so yeah maybe 38 38 what do you
think I can't remember a question how
many how many partners until it affects
a girl's mouth oh okay that's why I
wouldn't say that percentages
before marriage can I just answer that
can I say anything above two basically
yeah I was gonna say two I was gonna say
Third Time Lucky after two just get
married
yeah so
um after two it significantly goes down
it's like like 80 guys please don't
butcher me in the chat I know I know
it's like it goes down to roughly 50 but
after five Partners you have a 20 chance
of being in a happy marriage
so you go from an 80 chance to a 20 25
chance
how crazy he's just off the five
yeah because what are the odds that
that's you know the best you can do
right like that the guy the fifth one is
the one you're happy with like what was
wrong with the first second third and
fourth so maybe you're just never happy
I have no chance of marriage I just
thought to please
okay uh we are gonna react to an Amber
Rose clip
oh wait but first first should I read
the Super Chat yeah I'm trying to be
better guys
um if you have a comment guys all right
I need to have a talk with you
sometimes guys we need to be nicer in
the chat all right
um look I really
I'm gonna read them now and I I don't
actually even know what you guys put
because I haven't been watching
please don't make me say things where I
feel awkward all right like it's not fun
for me it's not fun for you well it's
very fun for you I can see the draw but
I'm just really looking forward to
having a bit nicer they if you got stats
questions thoughts that's fine but
personal attacks we're gonna try to stay
away from but you know you paid for
these so I'm gonna read them but you
know moving forward okay
Doug Bagley the difference is modern day
gardening tools are giving away their
value for free LOL you can have sexual
compatibility and still have a horrible
relationship zentians oh hi Zone tians
um fun fact sentience was my first super
chatter I when I did my first show a
year ago he was the first one to give me
like a big super chat and I was I kept
going so he's been here for over a year
zentians women should and do have the
freedom to act like 304s but what should
not be allowed nor tolerated is
accepting them as they are hoes don't
want to give the same acceptance to men
if you were 304 stay on that corner and
accept the consequence the blackest
Panther sleeping around is not the only
thing that makes you a 304 having 304
friends supporting 304 behavior and
putting thirst traps online are all 304
Behavior
which by default makes you a 304 dragon
stallion1001
would a woman marry a guy that is 25 000
in debt no you wouldn't that's the way
the men look at bodies for women each
one puts a thousand dollars in debt so
why is it bad for a man not to want to
marry a woman with 25 bodies 25 times a
thousand equals 25 000. yeah fun fact I
asked guys would you rather have a girl
with fifty thousand dollars in debt that
you have to pay off or 50 bodies all of
them pick the debt obviously yeah yeah
but if you're wondering um sentience
um just stopping by to show support you
cannot become unbecome a 304 as time
goes on she's just an older 304. just
like a murderer cannot be born again
there will always be one women always
try to re rewrite their sordid pass
gents focus on yourself Joe body count
LOL not frequency Michelle people keep
redefining what a prostitute is uh
delusional Maka rocks up Pearl it's
important to dis address the fact that
the law distinguishes between
prostitution stripping sure some who
strip are not prostitutes at all Carlos
strippers are 304s they dry hump for for
money a minute humble shark 25
um I've watched 30 shows and I'm not
subscribed wait am I subscribed damn it
be Panther 101 you always have a choice
you can make other way there's other
ways you can make money besides selling
your soul for money people want to take
the easiest way out and it's going to
make things harder along the Route or
along the line controversial videos and
gym all the strip clubs at my City sell
uh p word for fifty dollars
um blank blackest Panther would you be
okay with a man visiting a strip club
every day I mean they're not 304s and
they're also more promiscuous so what's
the issue he's just trying to understand
them from the inside out
um a scout and Brandy I have dated
strippers and yeah they are 304 as
privates and in the military Mary
strippers and go and ask them if their
wives are 304s I'm Alex hey Pearl first
time donating I love the show ladies uh
please rate yourself one through ten if
you were a seven
um and uh Pearl get the wet wipes out
okay we can do that rate yourselves one
ten what do you think you are 10 10. ten
ten eight eight five five YouTube
there's no room for improvement you're
perfect
yeah my mom went through nine months of
Labor to give birth to a perfect child
so I definitely say 10. so did everyone
yeah so I rate myself yeah there's no no
room for improvement who do you think's
attend in Hollywood
hmm
that's a good question
for me Chris Brown Chris I know a girl a
girl oh
Megan Good okay I'm gonna ask you two
questions do you think you could attract
Chris Brown because you're on the same
level
I have a great personality 100 do you
think you and Megan Good are on the same
level
in different ways okay you ten ten in
Hollywood I'm gonna put mine until an
8.5 an eight point Who's I feel like I
have I can improve myself okay who's
another 8.5 uh in Hollywood yeah
Hollywood TV whatever oh that's a good
question so if a 10 is Megan good that's
a good one she I would say she is 9 10.
so slightly below Megan good you know
slightly
[Music]
I really can't Chloe Kardashian I don't
know
never mind
um I really can't think of anyone right
now
no one out of the whole world
is this black right now I can't think of
it it's not English it's an English
models the black one no me yeah Naomi
Campbell okay you know I've met her fun
fact
no no I would quarter of an eight like
an eight nine I feel like she's still at
10 she looks good what about Laurie
Harvey where she
oh oh she's gorgeous she's definitely a
10 out of 10. okay is there anyone
that's not a tenants
uh what about
um someone told me that have you seen
Saved by the Bell um
okay blessing who would you say is an
8.5
I wanna let's get a guy's point of view
I'm very kind of tough so I'll say like
Megan Good is 8.5 to me she's not a 10.
okay he says you and Megan Good the same
no no but I would say Megan Good is a
it's a 10. okay what about you who's an
eight oh an eight
um
I say Georgia Smith
who Georgia Smith
she's at the UK
I need I need to get a Georgia Smith
she's gorgeous and that's okay
so you and her the same she's yeah
obviously she's got millions of pounds
which if I had I'd definitely be looking
after my buddy but yeah she's a
beautiful being okay who's the five
auntie
um what's that um whoopee
Whoopi Goldberg Whoopi Goldberg these
are five this is the big lady
yeah she's a five
Auntie she's old and she's a five
can I just say that you've got an
absolutely beautiful face okay so I
wouldn't give yourself a five I think
you should definitely Mark that up a bit
but just on my face you've seen the rest
of my books
yeah no no no no no no but she's better
than me
okay well you know I
I've got room for improvement there a
bit both freezing I've got room to make
them up till five okay do you think
being a five is an insult
um meet your average really doesn't it
yeah okay I don't think it's an inside
for average no what about you
um
isn't insulting to be average I mean if
someone told me I wasn't five yet yeah
you'd be insulted no I'm like because
some of us are five some of some of us
are ones some of us are tens okay yeah
steady Lane okay I'm gonna do something
that's just nice I think it's insulting
that they're trying to push me somewhere
where I'm not they're trying to if I say
that I'm same as I'm a number five I
think that's why you don't listen to him
because they lie to you because he's
like trying to say no you've got a nice
friend I think you're a six that's one
more point up that's a lot that's a lot
of people's skin you've got lovely eyes
you're really mysterious and gorgeous
okay we're not comparing you to a 20
year old we're comparing you to your age
about you how old is whoopee uh Whoopi
is no no no no no by the way we're not
comparing you for your age oh we're not
we're comparing a 10 is a hot model a
one is an 90 year old lady yeah so
that's good and the five is half that
yeah
so I'm still gaining okay so um one
I'm gonna I'm gonna do something all
right you rate everyone oh
my gosh
everyone in the room yeah everyone in
the room you can rate me too I won't get
offended okay
I would give you
a seven what I'm excited okay go ahead
I'd give you
7.5
I'll give you an eight thank you
I'd give you a 6.5
do I have to write blessing as well no
no just a minute no just a moment okay
yeah
Auntie raid everyone
five
yeah six six five six five
great everyone
eight
seven
six okay right everyone six
five five
eight six did anyone give anyone else if
other than Auntie did anyone give every
anyone else a five
interesting isn't it just interesting
how like no one's average
but like someone's got to be average
I'm not in the room you know I'd like
I'd like one day to have a program where
we've got loads of wet wipes and then
when people say that we make them take
off all their makeup that's why I gave
them yeah we should also have the chat
we could do it on that website you could
do not you can do a website where guys
will rate your like dating app pictures
and you can like put up anyways
um okay let's talk about what's her face
blessing pull up pull up the video
Amber Rose
one thing Amber Rose open invite to come
on the show I'd love to have you on this
couch right here yeah open invite to
Amber Rose guys go blow up her Instagram
and DM her okay next is doing mind your
business
[Applause]
foreign
we'll get all the views violence
stupid new challenge
a whole lot of ignorant dudes on the
news while in chicks booked for 2000
Post the new style and think about it
having no Talent that's the new Talent
I saw a chick on red carpet I said tell
me what you do she said I'm pretty piss
click titties belly button two I twerk
for the gram my videos get Hella bunch
of views that's very [__] cool but
tell me what you do it's disgusting they
say hoes women why
why is it disgusting because you're a
hater men are haters that women make
money and go get booked for 2 000
because they're [__] pretty no don't
hate the [__] hate the consumer
but he's saying it from an observatory
yeah and you're observing a [__] making
money
wait wait wait wait wait hold on let the
[__] Target check this out though check
this out look am I tripping check this
out now what about what about when you
did that what about the girl when she
did that right
for three months right now but then she
was gonna get 10 million from this
company but they've seen her do that
[__] and said nah
what is this why is that your business
herself it ain't you mind your business
stop policing dollars
all right I got a question if you knew a
woman was gonna make 10 million three
months from then he knows that who knows
the future of fortune teller you know
somebody that was gonna give her the 10
million yeah how about that but my whole
thing is
for the past three months
without nothing and don't conform
because they know what they're gonna be
later
you want somebody
thank you
[Applause]
let's face it
becoming approach Raider will take years
but you don't
blessing we don't got premium yet
oh okay is that it
oh there's more okay bring it back up
then
useful to even
oh there's not more
okay are you gaslighting me okay
should would you be okay
with your brother dating a woman that
has been publicly linked to rappers
entertainers
and Ballers for the last decade
dating it depends on what concept was
she's been known to date multiple
different you know like she dated Kanye
Future
um
I don't know
the rappers maybe Eminem maybe you know
Tristan Thompson you know the rappers
the entertainers
10 years
because it's public knowledge it
probably would bother me however she
wasn't famous she could have done the
same thing I just wouldn't know about it
because she's not in the Limelight but
if you found out she was doing that in
your town would you be okay with it
maybe they're not the famous ones but
like the town rapper the town baller
probably not I probably wouldn't like it
no you wouldn't like it what about you
no I wouldn't like it I wouldn't like my
brother dating someone knowing that
she's basically been around you know
foreign
do you think we should judge women for
sleeping around
um
if it depends I feel like you shouldn't
judge anyone based on anything if it's
their decision that's what they that's
what they want to do
um
again if it's to if it's a crazy
magnitude then everyone's gonna have an
opinion on it but
I don't think it's anyone's business if
anyone sleeps with to be honest okay go
ahead
yeah I agree because
it's not I don't feel like it's not nice
to judge people to be fair especially
based on how many people they've slept
with and whatever they're doing it's
their business so I don't really feel
like it's something that we should be
judging them on
yeah obviously we should we shouldn't
judge but we're humans and we always
have opinions and says and stuff like
that so
is what it is
I'm a human I would judge
I'm a judge even if I try not to judge I
know that I will judge
do you think that shaming women would
lead to better outcomes like if women
shamed each other more like if we said
strippers or [__] you know I'm not
gonna you know strippers are [__] if
you sleep around you're a [__] do you
think if we said that publicly if the
older generation said that to us if
everyone was saying that do you think
women would act differently or just be
quieter about it no because it happens
on a daily basis and if anything I think
it makes women Rebel even more
um oh you oh come on you think in this
culture
women are shamed for sleeping around
yeah and I think if that's what's made
things like only fans and things like
this become such a right thing because
it's like women are taking it as like no
they're it's to some women they're
empowering themselves by doing this I
think the more you shame someone and the
more you try and
say something's wrong is the more people
want to preview preview different but
don't you think that only fans is a
reward in a way
like how are they ashamed if they're
getting millions of dollars a month I
mean I know
a lot of girls are bad at only fans I
know they're not all making that but you
see what I'm saying yeah 100 but you
still means that there's still some
people that will see that content or
will know about it and go on their
social media and
um speak about it and judge someone
based on it so it's always whether what
you get paid and what you get what
someone says to you is two different
things okay what do you think I feel
like in this day and age and in this
Society artists feel like people are
very sensitive to comments and
you know judging people so if someone
was to shame you and if more people were
to shame women and that I definitely
feel like it would
it would it would stop or decrease oh
yeah what about you yeah I think
definitely if we were just a little bit
more vocal and had that old school
mentality about women respecting
themselves and cherishing themselves and
um sex being a little bit more sacred
definitely what do you think Auntie
public shaming
billboard type shame I think that's what
it's going to take and for and for like
single mothers of multiple baby fathers
I think they should be posters there
should be posters yeah nowadays they go
if you go in certain shops and you still
they've got like special websites in
there and like post Billboards and
newspapers and milk bottles shame them
all on there put them all on there if
you know a girl's got a high body count
and she can prove it put on shame or put
a picture up on the milk bottles and
stuff I think it should be everywhere
this girl's a [__] you drive past on
the bus do you know this Hall that's
what you should know well do you know
this 304 look are you the father of one
of these children you know with the
mother with like 10 different children I
think it should be ashamed publicly
because they're doing everything
publicly so I'm not showing them
publicly is it is it men's fault that
women sleep around
um oh it's a good question
um
yes I know
um because you've got two sides to a
coin so you've got some men will say
that women are frigid or on op aren't
sexually open because they withhold
having sex from someone which then could
make someone say oh okay so in order for
me to prove affection to someone I must
now mean that I have to speak with
people so it's got two sides to be coin
but I think it does have an impact yeah
so can I get a yes or no is it man's
fault yes or no
I don't think it's fair to say it's ever
in Titan whose fault is it more is it
the women or the man yeah yeah I would
say men's well it's more men's fault
yeah I think that women sleep around
yeah okay go ahead
I'm 50 50. now we got to pick one whose
fault is it that the women are sleeping
because I feel like
like we are in control of our own
actions so like I said are you sure she
thinks the men are in control of our
actions no but I just feel like you
yourself you're in control of your own
actions so you can't really blame
someone else for doing the actions that
you're wanting to doing so I can't
really say it's men's fault but at the
same time just the way Society is and
how
everything has become so
sexualized and like men like to push
women I just do feel like yeah whose
fault I can't is that what you call a
360. we got a yeah
what is it
uh
um I wouldn't say it's no it's women's
fault I need you it's a man's fault it's
men's fault okay what about you I'm 50
50 but if I had to pick it'll be it's
the woman's fault it's free will okay
yeah what do you think Auntie it's a
woman because the man can't have sex
unless she opens her legs end off
is it okay so if you hooked up with
Drake whose fault would it be would it
be Drake's fault or your fault that's
the back of my question though because
it's not just his best mixed race
saying if because you did it it's your
fault there's there's different aspects
to it and then there's the emotional um
your faults are Drake's fault it's a
mutual decision we both had sex 50 50
who's fault there is no one's fault in
that situation if you want to be black
and white with it it's no one's fault
who who is in control of sex
we by far we both are who who is to say
yes to sex both do both have to consent
okay if you hook up with Drake whose
fault is it
um it's your own fault you decided to do
what you wanted to do with Drake
oh we got her so now you're on you're on
the other it's the women's fault
that's why I can't say 50 50 because
it's just hard to say but yeah if you
want to sleep and drink then yeah that's
your old fault yeah I think I think that
it's a hundred percent the women's fault
100 because it's like all right all
right yeah you put a piece of meat in
front of a tiger you can't be mad he ate
it you put the piece of meat right in
front of him
now I know everyone will say pearl don't
control compare women to me
but I will I just
now yeah because men are in control of
relationships women are in control of
sex so we pick who we sleep with men who
pick who they wife you think that's true
false I think it's true nothing is true
for the majority oh so do we switch
teams you're back on my side it's the
women's fault
no I don't switch teams but that
particular statement I do agree with
okay
um would what percent of men do you
think are having sex
that are sexually active
it's called it's got to be High
um at least 90 90 or 75 75 7A
40 40. what if I told you one in three
men are either virgins or haven't had
sex in the past year
brothels I always think about brothels
oh no I think they just do the corn
thing what's the corn thing like I can't
say that oh YouTube
okay who's saying oh my God a high sex
drive and they're not getting it I mean
it must be hard for them because the
women are freeing them to the wrong
people yeah but I I was thinking that a
lot of men go to like brothels and stuff
like pay for it these days and then plus
some people ain't got the guts so just
stay at home you're miserable have a
white yeah well it's like why do you
think women hate man we're all sleeping
with the same ones what percent what
percent of men do you think are over six
foot nice not high at all yeah
twenty thirty percent Thirty thirty
percent fifteen wow
that means if you want a black one let's
talk and there's only a certain amount
of money that's gotta be like 0.5
Idris Elba basically um yeah I don't
find him sexy as well okay
um do you guys think that men wife
[__] yeah yeah 100 do you think the
men that wife the [__] know that
they're [__] yeah yeah they do know
definitely what do you think yeah
because I think to most men what I'm
learning is that if you see if anybody
other than him
your whole so yeah okay with the girls
so how many girls can you think of that
are [__] that have gotten married
well the first one that comes to mind is
cardi B like I mean she used to oh I met
in your personal life now
celebrities kind of live in a different
world like I don't I don't think we can
compare cardi B to the average gal so
how many people do I know that a horse I
got married yeah
at least six okay and what about do
their husbands know yeah and they don't
care probably not no okay yeah none of
my friends are married so sorry you
wouldn't because you're young how old
did you say you were 23 yeah okay okay
yeah I think I don't know many people
that got married but majority of yeah
[__]
have been married yeah so a lot what do
you mean they don't get married no I've
got fussy male friends
okay I'm gonna read the super chats
really quick before I get into the next
question
guys
the super chats have been better this
show they have been better so make sure
you guys like the video how many likes
do we need to get to a thousand what are
we trying to save for right now blessing
what what are you trying to buy what
equipment are you trying to run me dry
with what are you what are you trying to
do to me now you're trying to get Amber
Rose here to do a one-on-one interview
guys so super chat for that we're on
2000 lakhs today
did you did you open the chat for him
yeah you didn't you didn't Gaslight them
did you none sometimes blessing
gaslights the chat nah nah they're free
today they've been excellent okay okay
um
all right guys let me all right culture
um if you want to know what men are
looking for what for watch the guy with
the it's me channel um AO stupid it's
mind-blowing that every day women choose
to end up that women's choices do end up
being men's fall act your age see
Dumbledore for the only way 304s are
above average is in their BMI
um kawari men are like cheese never more
than five varieties at a time where they
will spoil um each cherish for the
individual they are they're lovers but
true friends as well
um everyone judges all the time
comparing others to your own morals and
standards if you don't call a spade a
spade you become an enabler enabling
delusion enabling bad behavior and bad
outcomes bring back the Scarlet letters
oh my gosh we should bring back a
Scarlet Letter every show if anyone says
anything or wrong they get a hold of it
that'd be funny
um okay get the likes up and do all the
YouTube stuff Joe D um LOL when your
body is your biggest asset
Spanky world if a man has one quality
aft you're after second man needs the
second quality the third quality Etc
you're happy regrets get great um the
men get rare and not existent keep up
the great work reclaim your throne there
are no tens on the panel you can't be a
10 as a woman in over 200 pounds you all
are not bad bees at all coming from a
six-figure man with an eight pack
zentians ladies who are not an eight
nine or ten you have no never had those
level of outcomes meaning businesses
aren't after you like them the consumers
of products dictate the price range or
rating in the case men are the consumers
of women's Beauty a scout the only ten I
can think of is Gina Carana I don't know
what that is
um Jody not trying to hate on these
women but these numbers are delusional
the UK Economist sleeping around proves
that all those past men didn't see you
as wife material therefore the more
bodies you have the less you are
deserving as a wife I'm David McQueen
um one on the right acts like a female
the female Admiral or act back I don't
know what that means um Lucky Luciano
Pearl I'm gonna need you to clean that
laptop by C finger
that's true okay fine
um Ben tomsky why do we believe that
casual sex with a lot of people briefly
somehow prepares you for monogamy and
commitment to one person someone
explained the difference is modern day
gardening tools are given oh wait I read
that already
um do you guys think there's any value
in Saving yourself or your husband so
having less partners for a future
husband
yeah I think so you think so definitely
yeah yeah yeah yep why
because I can understand why it would be
a sacred thing to share just yourself
with only one person and that person's
the person you commit to
yeah just
it's important to save yourself to that
person like as a Christian myself I just
feel like that's a very sacred thing so
yeah
um and definitely about quality and
usually if the woman's gone through a
few guys she's going to be damaged
mentally emotionally spiritually maybe
physically as well
auntie
let me just answer a question about
virgins and getting married yeah and
didn't they I was just saying that the
answers I gave the first time and the
answers they gave this time maybe maybe
they're they changed their minds with
new information I don't know is the way
you ask the question is this the same
question but in a different way yeah
sometimes
I don't think it's the same question
it's a different because I it's a little
different it's kind of the same but when
you're saying about virgins getting
married and they were saying no it
doesn't matter if you're not a virgin
you know yeah but but if you ask it in a
different way I don't know I think it's
the same as what I said before that
they're less they're better are those
your slippers auntie I don't know they
might be yours I can't find oh no I
couldn't figure out where they came from
I've got two pairs and I was thinking
you probably left him here yeah the
cream pair yeah I gave him I gave them
to the intern yeah but you can have them
back
because I was like whose are these I was
like I don't know where they came from
okay
um just getting um so going back to my
[__] my horror um tweet I just want to
clarify what's a [__] and what's not a
[__] and I just think as a panel We
could decide does getting an abortion
make you a [__]
if not does getting 10 abortions make
you a [__]
no it doesn't I don't know
I don't see how abortion just makes you
oh no no it doesn't make you what about
the 10 a 10 not even a little bit
no ten ten crazy yeah yeah wow
okay no no the fact that you got there
to have to go and have 10 abortions yes
you're right that yes it does make you
hot I don't think it makes you a whole I
just no that's just I think it's just
wild overall I don't think it makes you
a [__] because that just means you
could die yeah it could be the same guy
but I have 10 abortions is crazy what if
you've only had one partner but you had
10 abortions you were a stripper and you
had only fans [__] not a [__]
you know I hope I just use a condom I
don't understand whatever makes you a
hole though not a [__] just watch this
what'd you say auntie worthless you're
worthless
I say what less but yeah
if you've read like 10 abortions
sometimes as women we just can't call
speed speed
you know it's like okay she might not
have had sexual a bunch of sexual
partners
but if you've had 10 abortion
something's wrong like he's a
hysterectomy
after after about three or four
abortions it should be mandatory
hysterectomy which they should be I'm a
firm believer in that
do you feel like your standards have
gotten higher or lower the older you've
gotten or the same lower
higher higher higher higher the same the
same how have your standards gotten
higher for you two like what were your
standards before and what are your
standards now and then I before it was
just I didn't really think too much into
it I would kind of just talk to someone
and then accept them as a day off but
now it's like
a conscious except them as who they are
because it's depending like they could
have some sort of issues that I would
not necessarily want to deal with and
just me growing myself I don't
necessarily have time to deal with those
things so now I'm just like I have just
a certain image that I
yeah
okay go ahead sorry mine's quite similar
to hers it's more standards in a sense
of more patience and just having given
time to get to know people and also
knowing that you know a lot of things
are like the surface level
um and that's what most guys are
searching for is is the body so just
given our time to get to know someone
mentally emotionally and more so
what'd you say about the body I'm saying
that most guys are asked you for sex
so it's about just knowing that and
having that you know they're giving you
the gift of the Gap and telling you what
you want to hear just because you want
to get your knickers and it's not
because they genuinely care about you or
they actually really want to get to know
know you I think that takes time
okay
do you think we should
we create a more sex positive culture
um
not necessarily sex positive
um I don't think it needs to be
um advertised anymore
necessarily by for those who do it it is
what it is I don't think it needs to be
publicized any further okay so I should
start tweeting that strippers or horse
yes well no it's your opinion but I
don't feel like it needs to be I don't
think it needs to be popular any further
I would argue that's a fact I I would
argue that's a fact in your opinion yeah
well we could say opinion right but then
then you look up the definition of a
[__] right it says prostitution
but you know which you could argue
they're not because they're technically
not having sex or you could argue they
are
because they're taking off their clothes
for money
but that's but it's not tomatoes tomato
like to me
a fact
okay he's still set in six isn't it at
the end of the day
but if you're actually physically having
sex or visually having sex
still selling sex
so why don't you sell sex you're a
prostitute
I'm just getting into I'm just saying
technically sexy sex what about you
should we create a more sex positive
culture
I feel like it's already out there
enough I don't think it needs to be
advertised anymore okay like yeah no I
think we definitely do need to create a
more sex positive culture because sex is
natural that's how we're created this
it's something that we can't help but
it's how we
you know cultivate that and get into
that I.E not sleeping with loads of
people that's to the guys as well I've
got young sons and I try to teach them
to be celibate put your energy into your
sports and into your careers and
hopefully when you elevate you can give
yourself to a woman that you know is
decent but also you've got all the STIs
and STDs whatever they're called and the
sexual like the energy transfer and I
think in that way we need to be more
educated it's not about like oh sex is
bad sex is not bad we're not gonna stop
and I think because we haven't really
taken on face value in Black okay sex is
natural this is why we do have all the
corn and um
you know the essay and whatever because
we're restricted and we feel dirty and
it's not like it's natural just find one
person that you Vibes with and you know
build that relationship with them get to
know each other so how would how would
we create a more sex positive culture
I think by educating ourselves a lot
more about it like I think that we need
to really get into this whole thing of
energy it matters you know every person
should how should we educate so if
you're gonna are you gonna educate kids
are you going to educate teenagers when
do we start the education yeah I think
we should start the education in schools
because it's normal okay
um I think when puberty starts so like
13 14 yeah yeah so at 14 years old how
do you educate do you tell them how to
have sex no I think you should tell them
about the feeling it's a guide yeah no I
think we should tell them about the
feelings that they're going to
experience you know
um and what they might want to do but I
think we have to educate them on a moral
value to be like look you might have
these feelings and this energy but you
have to kind of hold it within yourself
until you find somebody that you really
connect with and usually don't find that
and so you can pay a bill and so you can
go and if you can't get a job and work
you can't be having sex that's the way I
say to my boys like if you can't take a
girl and a date and treat a good you
can't be having sex with her and do you
think that's a conversation the schools
should be having or the parents it's a
joint thing it like they say what is it
it takes the what is it a village to
raise a child and that's what we need to
do between all of ours okay and so you
would tell them not to the message that
education would be telling them don't
have sex until you can have a job
basically yeah okay okay
um what's sex positive what do you say
sex positive should we create a more sex
positive culture no
sex negative yeah
how would you do that Auntie you still
don't have it then they have um in
America somewhere where they have those
um
is it celibacy
when they go around the schools and
stuff that's what I grew up getting
that's right and that's it that's the
city speakers that's what they should do
and we had no everyone's set okay I had
a certain I'm not gonna name names
certain someone say oh the Catholic
schools were so bad look it I don't know
what Catholic schools you all went to we
had no teen pregnancies in my my high
school and we did chat that's the thing
I would say oh if you don't have sex ed
you guys are gonna go crazy I'm like no
we were much better than the public
schools I mean there were a lot of
Catholic schools that I knew that were
nearby and
the girls had plenty of sex didn't get
pregnant because they use really good
contraception but they were snags
yeah the Catholic girls were the worst
like it that wasn't my high school
wasn't like that it like as my Mom said
that undercover horse
yeah I feel like in and also is the
Public Schools they're just wild and
like we didn't even have parties or
anything with us or if we did I wasn't
invited maybe they had them and I just
wasn't if I thought you was not funny in
England that the Catholic girls their
world when they get loose I find that
all girls schools yeah yeah we should
normally yeah yeah England America two
different things that girls are wild
yeah I think in America like they've got
real like what they stand for they stand
for they mean it we're here it's you can
just kind of do what you want to do and
there's no strength in any beliefs
really we don't really have the strong
religious belief where like in America
like they had all those you know groups
and it means something you stand by
something it's your word sure or not
yeah
um
I read super chats one more time
do you think wait do you think that
changed like that England used to be
like have more of what you were just
talking about yeah cultures standards
when do you think it's switched um I
think when the internet was
um blew up and also I think when we just
started integrating cultures
um I think that's when it kind of just
messed up a little bit because it was
kind of all we all lost our way
basically I think
got it got it
um okay I'm gonna refresh this thing sir
I think it was
when everybody started copying everybody
like the internet opened it up so
everybody started copying America and
here and there or whatever but I just
think that
it's just they've got too many laws in
England that protect the children
that's what it is you can't do nothing
with your children anymore to protect
them
and I think that's what it is but I
think the internet has got a lot and
just like following other people just
like thinking The Grass Is Always Green
on the other side whatever mama always
says that if America gets a cold we
sneeze
you know and that's the way it's worked
can I just say as well I think it's like
the drugs and alcohol culture
um because obviously that affects you
and everybody gets all free-minded and
free spirit aired and starts loving
everybody and whatever whatever yeah and
the music because the drugs the drink
the music share it across the world the
media I think that's different I think
in the 70s it was all in the 70s it was
all free love now it's just like sex
drugs I'll [__] everybody yeah but
that's back in the day it was
psychedelic so open it up to your
spiritual self where now it's cocaine
and and MDMA or whatever and that just
messes you up that makes you think it's
something that you're not people don't
know if they ever need that to get to
get to go on how they're going yeah well
then all the men need is a is a good
outfit you can have a good man that
looks like a [__] in the week all the
man needs is one good outfit I said that
that we should do that experiment go and
get a [__] off the streets clean him up
get him a good outfit and hire a car for
the day and just give them like a cup of
100 pounds and go into a club and pick
up any girl he wants Shout and then let
him turn up the next day how he normally
looks
and then nobody's gonna want it because
that's all it takes it's a good outfit
and a car half of the minute did they
hire the cars anyway they don't belong
to them they're just getting free sex
you know for a lifetime you know you
think it's that easy for guys yeah it is
we should do it I think it's that easy
for a guy to go and get it because women
nowadays they're so loose and all they
care about is you got there seriously
get a guy put chain on him and get him
some name brand clothes and all that
belugiana or whatever their name is and
give him a car you know and turn them
outside a nightclub guaranteed put him
on the table with a great big bottle of
champagne as well with some other men
that look like him the girls are gonna
Rush him
I don't know I went okay so I probably
would have thought like that I went to
have you guys know what pickup is so
pickup is basically where men learn how
to get laid okay so you know it started
with and I'm probably gonna butcher this
a little bit sorry chat but there's
certain guys that really pickup artist
so it's called Neil Strauss the game and
it was him dealing with these guys that
basically teach other men how to get
laid there's videos on YouTube so like
for example
one thing they would teach which is a
bit more PG is to make sure to touch the
girl not in like a weird way but how are
you going to go home with a guy if he
hasn't touched you all night like have
you ever heard a guy try to take you
home and like you literally haven't
touched once the whole day like how are
you gonna feel comfortable okay that's a
PG version so I when I was doing
research on this channel I went to a
pickup boot camp and these guys would
pay
thousands of dollars to be taught for a
weekend how to get laid Sims look look
I'm not gonna look but here's the thing
Andy they were more normal I mean well
it was a wide variety but some of them
were more normal than you thought that
would like and it kind of put me in the
men's point of view because you know
you're kind of helping them you're like
oh go up to that girl or go up to that
girl and I could not believe like how
harsh girls were to these guys like even
if they had a nice suit on or they I I
would say like some of them were better
looking than the girls like they would
they would reject them so harshly you
know why because anybody any man that
pays a couple of grand for that ain't
got that ain't got the pizza and then
that's a talk to a girl the girl just
wants to wear all that [__] talk the
smooth talk that the men do and that's
what they're missing yeah so it's like
how do you how do they change their
personalities even even if even if you
get the suit and put them in VIP then
yeah you can't like one guy had talked
to me about world domination yeah he was
gonna like be a conqueror
and he was gonna like conquer the world
I was like what nobody's one of those
that go and dress up in army costumes
and playing fields at the end of the
week auntie I don't know you know you
should go to um
um is it erotica Expo they do that they
do an expo we're very Frank erotic and
they do classes in there you want me to
go to that I'll take you
guys together I'll find out when it is
wait I'll find it blow your mind what
would it what would I do there no is it
is this like a great big um you know how
you have a Comic-Con Comic-Con
Expedition yeah and then you have a
erotica Expedition
I've been I've been as well that's where
I met Vita dantees okay I'm gonna get
put a cage and hang up from the ceiling
okay
um reclaim your throne my rose son found
out he's embarrassed around his peers of
girls are narcissists who sacrifice
their children's mental health for
pleasure and money absolutely apparent
um western western hose are zinc dumps
nothing more EIP jungulin um stop trying
to change hoes we need hoes for the
world to go around men need recreational
use or men that aren't ready will have
to commit in order to get some action
whose side are you on
you're right my bad my bad
um Taylor uh men have to have a contract
to provide support and offer ourselves
um for our family women have their side
of the contract when this breaks down
the family breaks down um Society breaks
down the clue Channel
um the U.S must have a really good
publicist in the UK standards are a
thing of the past here I'm NSX Pearl
your analogies have been on point lately
great stuff lazy Prodigy with all due
respect I'm worried for all men raised
with modern women they will be more
feminine versus masculine I'm culture
find men become less sexually attracted
to a Woman They to a woman the longer
they are with her the Coolidge effect
scientifically confirmed oh that's
interesting
a less okay
um Dylan Pearl do you have plans to head
to Vegas and talk to Rolo I saw Rolo's
episode on about sauce cast not reading
super chats and you and Rolo were going
at it in the chat
um no
um you know I did try that once and I I
just wasted some money and time so I'd
rather not you know do that again
um
Cayenne gray can you explain what a 304
means for the chat
um Sylvester Gooding paid for sex at
least here safe in regards to getting an
STD you actually get sex so that is a
guarantee I'm culture fine if you want
to oh I read that one already let me
just refresh the chat really quick
um
okay
I'm surprised at those super shit's well
done what do you mean you're surprised
oh they're being nicer mean yeah they're
being good it's been nice
I know I sometimes if I skipped any no I
haven't I look I I like to read them
because they pay for them but sometimes
I'd like to read your sometimes
I have really horrible ones
okay do you guys think that if a girl is
a single mother that the man and the
women are equally responsible
what do you mean so if a woman's a
single mother who's responsible the man
or the woman
as in parents and they're both
responsible they're equally for an
unplanned pregnancy would you say
okay but sorry I'm gonna rephrase the
question I didn't ask you right
um who's more responsible for an
unplanned pregnancy the man or the woman
both equal 50 50. okay what do you think
50 50. no it's the woman's
responsibility is her responsibility to
protect herself and be on the pill or
any form of contraception she knows her
body at the end's day so it's not 50 50
it's 100 woman's responsibility not all
women can take contraception
condoms
yeah that's the man's responsibility no
no it's not I mean to put it on we have
an unprotected sex and if there's a
possibility she could get pregnant the
only women put on condoms come on
nothing
no I mean put condoms on men
you want to make sure it fits properly
put it on yourself why women looking at
that you'll get a dick in your hand
you'll suck a dick but you won't put a
condom on please
I'll condom on yourself you never
learned that get a cucumber put it on
yourself
squeeze the tip get all the air out put
it on yourself then you know it's on
properly so no I think that women should
carry condoms just as much as men
men put them on women put them on
because at the end of the day it's your
dick put it on
you agree with that
yeah I do agree with that yeah so you
change your mind
I don't think there's still two people
having sex though do you think they have
equal amounts of choice
in regards to getting pregnant no in
regards to contraception
so like for example I as a woman you can
track when you're ovulating the men
can't do that
the women we can be on the pill and we
can lie to them hypothetically about the
pill they can't do that they could stop
holding a condom so could we yeah so
that's what I mean yes sorry but that
one's 50 50. right so he could stab
holes we could stab holes but when it
comes to the birth control
they have no male contraception they
can't track when we're ovulating if
you're just casually hooking up
have you ever thought about that before
I haven't in that context now if I'm
being completely honest that's okay you
can you know you're able to change your
mind on the Pod if if you if you are
convinced sorry Auntie go ahead I was
gonna say when it comes to stabbing
condoms that's what you have to carry
around
you carry it on you open your and you
put it on yourself then you know don't
trust no man and no man should trust no
woman always make sure you see them open
up the packet or you open up the packet
yourself
true
and what about
um abortion so like women have the
choice to get an abortion and men don't
so if you're a single mother or you have
an unplanned pregnancy you could end it
if you wanted to where men can't
so because of that would you then put
more of the responsibility on the women
yeah why would it not contact showered
okay what what percent would you give
men
um I'd say it's probably in based on
everything that you've just said I'd say
it's maybe actually like more 70 women's
responsibility than men okay 70 percent
do you think eighty percent eighty
percent
Auntie what do you think
I think that other than the exception
stand to the woman for unplanned
pregnancy once it's unplanned and you
get pregnant and once the man knows that
you said you don't want no kids
then I think it's down to the woman and
I think that she should hold all
responsibility I don't think she can
answer a man for a penny yeah in that
situation I agree I think once the man
hasn't said I want a child or he's told
you that I don't want a child and the
woman gets pregnant I got pregnant on
the pill and I feel the same way I think
it's down to the woman your child you
look after it because at the end of the
day you don't have to keep it and if you
decide to keep it in a man don't want it
you look after it
you choose to have it
so you have it because if you didn't
want it you would choose not to have it
and if a man didn't want it then
if you was pregnant and you didn't want
to have the child and your man said I
want you to have the job he's got no
choice in the matter so why should you
want all the choices you have to charge
you have all the choice whoever's got
the child have the choice
if you don't want to make that choice
have the children give it over to the
father
that's just my view
do you think certain women are proud to
be [__] yes
why do you think that is
um like I said before I think so I'm
gonna find it they they find it a form
of empowerment to say that they can do
what they want with who they want as
many times as they want for their
Messiah breaking them breaking the mold
essentially I think some women will find
it as are they aware usually of how men
feel about it yeah I think they are so I
think is quite known how men feel
towards women that are more promiscuous
than others and do you think men should
feel bad for them and be empathetic
towards them if they become born again
later
no not necessarily I mean
if amount everyone has their own
preference you can't force someone to
want to be with someone who has had sex
with loads of people if it's their
opinion like no I don't like that's not
for me that's perfectly fine you're born
again a horse you get a born again pimp
they've got to be around there somewhere
um okay go ahead
do you think some women are proud to be
[__] yeah definitely and why do you
think that is I don't know they're just
they're just very open about it so
they don't really have no shame against
it so they just they are who they are
and do you think they're aware of how
men generally feel about it yeah they
are aware but I think they care they
just don't care they honestly don't and
you do you think later if they they do
the
you know the type the born again I got
three different baby daddies and now I'm
in the church you you know the time you
know she's laughing you know the time
you're thinking of someone
I didn't say you I'm just joking
um do you think men should believe it
and feel bad for them later now I feel
like they should believe it because at
any moment you can change but I mean at
the end of the day
you put an image of yourself out there
so it's kind of hard for others to kind
of accept this new change of yours
um especially for men so yeah but I
still feel like at the end of the day
men should accept that because anyone
can change do you know any Horrors that
have genuinely changed uh not really so
you don't know any
possible but I do think it's possible
yeah
do you think it's likely
yeah you think it's likely but you don't
know any I don't know anybody do you
think it's likely
okay
so then why why would a guy believe it
if if you don't know any yeah but just
because I don't know any doesn't mean
this other there are no other woman's
out there that I want I mean unicorns
exist
s
[Laughter]
but they could be out there yeah but
that's supposed to be this is like we've
like I've I don't necessarily know any
but I believe that there are women out
there that will definitely change okay
what about you
um I don't think any woman's proud to be
a [__] I think that it's a fake facade
that she's putting on and a delusion
um usually women that are [__] they're
usually Intoxicated by something bless
them or they're distracted so I'm saying
that Amber's talking about money money
is a distraction because when you're by
yourself
naked in the mirror or talking to your
psychiatrist you're not proud of how
you're feeling no woman feels good being
with multiple men every woman and every
guy I realistically would like to find
that person that they can connect with
so I'm saying like the more guys that
you sleep with it just it's chipping at
you your soul your body everything so
for you to say that you're proud of that
you're lying you're lying to yourself
you're lying to society and everybody
knows it
that's what they were over the place I
went there proud to be [__] because
society makes them proud
that's what I think and they they get
full bother guys because look at all the
videos all the the the rap videos all
the videos and you see the ton of girls
in there it's popular so why wouldn't
they want to be a [__] and if they want
to sleep with that guy at the end of the
day they don't mind because they get
somewhere
and I think they're proud to be yours I
think they're getting money through
they're getting Fame now it's all about
getting money quick and getting Fame
quick best way for a woman to get money
quicker to take her clothes off or look
half naked
have you got a nice Twerk It Jiggle your
breasts around and you've got it made
nowadays you'll be there everyone thinks
they're in a movie in a music video
basically that's the culture
yeah get rich quick so yeah
people are proud to be yours it's only
when they get old and they realize that
the world seldom will lie but that time
they are washed up and nobody really
wants me for anything
do you think women in general care what
men want
yeah they do
what do you think
yeah hmm what do you think oh I don't
think the modern day woman does I think
when you find that woman that's a little
bit more mature and
still a bit cultured
um yeah we do care what I mean our men
want but the Modern Woman no they don't
care what do you think well if it would
not give a [__] till they get old and
lonely they really want a man then they
decide to investigate and find out what
a man wants but I don't think they care
so what what do men want
um as in a relationships they're set in
in let's say a wife if he's looking for
a wife what does he want in a wife what
does he want her to do what does he want
her to act like he wants it to be a
nurturer he wants her to look after
house and home he wants to look after
him
um
and he wants yeah that's I think that's
what men want in a woman which is what
her job should be is which is to nurture
and look after the Homemaker house at
home for a man
how would she make a house a home what
are some examples cooking and cleaning
and
um it's women that women it's a women's
touch to a house that makes it homely
um
that's your journey for a pearl we're
Wrecking
so can I have some specific examples
like because I always hear that make a
house and do a home like how
specifically would you make a house into
a home
um I think it's just little things that
men don't think of like and like the
organization standard like a lot of men
you go into their home it's just very
basic like women I'd accents like
candles and cushions and blankets and
yeah but it makes dust collectors it
makes it feel more it makes it feel more
homely than it does than just like a
shell or something
okay
um can you name something that she
didn't say that you think men want
definitely like taking care of the
children as well
um
basically all the things you said is
what I would agree with but yeah the one
thing she did was taking care of the
children
um definitely makes it at home okay
what about you um I think nowadays men
are looking for like a partner so
someone that they can have like an
honest
um conversation with about work maybe
business ideas their feelings someone
that just kind of understands them and
doesn't judge them too much
do you think that's what men want one
thing yeah I think they want a lot more
obviously I want I think they want
someone open sexually
um someone that's loyal funny
um clean yeah I think on all rounds are
everything you listed sounded like what
women want from men yeah because we both
want the same from each other no what do
you say what do you think
um I think one thing that you didn't no
one mentioned is fit fit yeah like BMI
skinny small tiny yeah but maybe with a
butt but a small one for sure they don't
have a choice I think they just want a
hole They Don't Really Care what's
around the whole I mean I think it
depends like if a guy has a Jew okay
does Leonardo DiCaprio
date fat chicks or thin chicks do NBA
that's like average guys I know but
that's what I'm saying when when the men
have all the choices in the world it's
like the most beautiful women in the
world who do they date the rich men yeah
right the most handsome tall successful
men in the world who do they date the
models that's because society makes it
no that's what is attractive and that's
what's known to be it's the fact that
they that's more attractive people are
respected more by people because that's
that's the standard that's been set but
if that was the case you wouldn't get
big women that get married if if that's
all men want is a skinny person
essentially
um well I mean there's always going to
be someone like I mean one out of three
men are having sex with anyone so
there's always going to be there's
always going to be someone but again I
think you can really see what men want
and like what do they do when the men
that have all the choice who do they
pick
yeah because that's that's the standard
look at George Michael when before he
came out as gay he was seen with models
because it wasn't known to be so what's
your I'm just kidding what's your
premise your premise is that they're
dating them because they're dating the
pretty models because society's telling
them they yeah they could have an
underlying fetish for someone but
they're not going to come out and do
that because Society doesn't deem that's
the type of person that you should be
with as a successful person no I I don't
think so I think like because I mean
being overweight that says something
about you you know it's like it's your
lifestyle choices so if you're in shape
why would you want to date someone
that's not because some people have have
uh have things for people that are of
different right but then but then when
they have the choice to date a fat chick
or a thin chick and they pick the thin
chick
wouldn't that indicate that men like
beautiful thin models yeah but it also
goes back to my point of that's what's
picked as a whole don't get me wrong
some people do like that that type of
body type however Society deems that
that's the type of person that's known
that you should be with because of your
stature and Calabar that doesn't mean
that that you some people will find
other body shapes attractive however
when you're in the Limelight if it were
to be of a bigger girl they're going to
get stick for it because why are you
with the fat chick how essentially how
does society shame that when we have
movements like body positivity for women
and not for men
he who said this name there's no
movement for
um what do you put the TV for man
because anytime a bigger woman is on any
social media and receives pushback she
has all these women coming to her
defense but we can [__] on a short man
all day or a broke man all day because I
don't want no scrub scrub is it like you
see and as well and Victoria's Secret
who do they have on the covers
they have the big chicks now
but it's I still not even though that's
the case you still have those people
that come in and say why are you
promoting and why are you advertising
for people to be overweight so it still
it still has a backlash too but it's
still seen as negative lizzo she gets it
all the time for Being for being big as
she said
I was about to say that
we don't really don't understand years
and years and years ago
four years football
I used to get sick for being skinny Slim
and all the all the big women are out
there
but then they were there was a change
because all the big women got all the
men they all slept around which left the
skinny women with low body counts
and now most of the fat women there when
they run
and they're still fat
and I'm skinny yeah you fat women and
I'm skinny
and I'm loving it I'm absolutely loving
it because the amount of slagging up I
used to get for being skinny but with
the fat birds out there saw the fat
birds I'm glad that you're still fat
because nobody really wanted the fat
birds the fat birds in back in the day
we're good for shagging
that's what they're good for bouncing on
I mean me quite frankly it's quite clear
that I'm fat and I don't it doesn't
really bother now I said before your day
oh now
skinny birds when I'm happy
I'm not happy that it's coming when I'm
old do you know what I mean but I'm just
happy that it's come back again
that's skinny checks okay I feel like
it's it's always been there but they've
always had us away or made us look
really anorexic like those models and
then that I think that's what it is they
went too far with the modeling and you
know the skinniness they were like
looking anorexic and then all of a
sudden they went from all those mother
to to skinny to now there's certain
clothes shops that I go into and I can't
buy clothes my size they don't start in
my size
and if I do do my size they start from
like size eight to size 32. why am I
going to play the same price as
somebody's a size 32. they use more
material than me no plus size clothes
are more expensive
yeah but if that shop does small sizes
then I should get a percentage of at
least half price because I'm half their
size
Auntie do you think it's society that
makes men
um the rich
successful man
deep models you think it's Society
telling them to do that no why do you
think they do it because they can who
wouldn't want to if there was a poor man
he wasn't successful and somebody said
oh you can get a model why wouldn't you
why would somebody successfully want to
go of an ordinary person anyway
unless they were there with them from
the beginning and we could look at it
both ways I mean would you rather date
Chris Brown Chris Brown or what's his
name oh my God I can't think of his name
the the dude that was on Fresh
I like it
see I hate it when you get to a certain
point because people might actually see
it when you say their names
um
who's that guy with the curly hair from
the movie
I can't think of his name but I mean I
feel like it works both ways though like
I mean I just think in the people with
the most options tend to pick In-Shape
people on both ways you don't think
that's true
no well not at the moment and apparently
I bought that boards are the thing
that's in right now
is there a dad bod calendar
I I wouldn't I'm not looking for one
person but
that builds it in
no well I see all over the Internet is
Dad buds at the moment because scissor
released a song I don't remember how it
goes but she was basically saying get
yours get yourself a big guy's basically
yeah
I don't think a big guy is a dad bought
though a dad board is someone that don't
work out is just don't look after
himself like because I think it's
difficult because some people they're
born overweight and big jump saying
nobody getting born overweight no no no
no no okay obviously but as they grow
into toddler you know and I've got
experienced personal experience I've
seen it they're like they was born that
size and they raised that size like
Society is changing which I'm saying we
can't be so shallow to be like okay
someone's body the way they look like
it's all about that person what they're
attracted to you know what I'm saying
yeah we can talk in general and so like
in general people are more attracted to
thinner people healthier people than how
about that healthier people people with
their BMI intact I don't care no baby
ain't born big and if they're born big
then by the time they start running
around they lose weight
they start losing weight no you do the
right people are a beast and losing
weight anybody that's obese is like a
discipline if a child's obese the mother
need the parents need locking up that
child should be taken away from them any
obese if you've got a child it's obese
they should give you a warning and if
you don't stick to the diet then you
should lose your job
that's my opinion but I think it's you
know we need to clarify the fact that
some guys and some girls do like bigger
girls or guys like I've dated chunky
guys I've got a little bit of a belly
whatever because it's not a big it's not
that big a deal you know it's a little
bit different when they're like really
really really big to women and to men
some men like big girls it's it's
usually because they have no other
choice okay
if you line up 10 fat chicks and 10 thin
chicks most men are gonna pick the thin
chicks over the fat chicks if both of
both of them want you know unless one's
a freak and he's a feeder
but it's like we talk about in general
we don't talk about it you know what I
mean like there's exceptions sure but
it's not the time
um like come on
you're gonna pick this no
I'm gonna give you
Chris Hemsworth shirtless let's just
we're just gonna go who are you picking
this this one
or this one
I've been out bigger than that probably
bigger than that
okay yeah
the great he had a great he had a great
person sorry I showed them this
versus versus
this I just picked Chris Hemsworth yeah
okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
um Auntie you can think of a question
for after okay yeah I'll give you I'll
give you a question privileges
yeah
yeah for being such a great a great
guest on Saturdays okay
Senor sticks why is there no such thing
as a mom bod
um something when you're saying big do
you when why are you saying big when you
mean fat and obese
maybe I'll start
a scout and a Bradley am I like bigger
women but I still want her fit I also
want someone who can keep her mouth shut
loyalty Family Values I'm a
multi-millionaire and I'm fit and over
six feet tall silly sausage men just
don't a wife sweating on their kids
um take Queen the Lane Bryant chick in
white is in denial silver scale proud to
be a passport to buy by Western women
Danny advice needed if men are not
monogamous then what do women who cannot
handle that emotionally do stay single
um a bold and Malik when I became Muslim
I had four children by three different
men and I've been married and widowed
and can choose to marry again anytime
Muslim men have loved my kids more than
their biological fathers anyone can
change culture find
do you think that men in the UK will
start leaving for other countries as the
passport Bros are not just black
Americans I'm Chris Rock a born-again
virgin is like trying to
fix a broken vase it just doesn't hold
water a scout and Bradley please bring
Mama Pearl back
um yeah when I go to the US I'm probably
going to do a one-on-one interview with
her with blessing lazy Prodigy
probability versus possibility H2O
mechanic um who's more desirable and has
more value a woman 44 with three kids
and has a body count of three or a woman
25 no kids but a body count of 50.
a blessing you got to pick this one who
you picking a woman she's 44 with three
kids or a woman that's 25 or sorry a
woman 44 three kids body count of three
or a woman 25 no kids body Counting 50.
yeah I think I'm I'm hi buddy count I
know
damn it's a hard choice
I'm gonna I'm not gonna be a step daddy
so I'll tell you what I'll take the
other one
um sick Taiwanese feminization of the
Western countries in the EU U.S has been
overly negative in every way why do you
think we don't fight back against this
recovering nihilus I'm glad rental cars
exist but I never wanted to own one but
rental cars can be cleaned and renovated
that's not true of woman
boneman 538 all for being a father for
the record but not for the with the
horror of Babylon
um Matt Stone yeah you think it's 50 50.
but we lose custody and pay child
support and you decide to keep a child
we don't want we get punished even if we
do provide
um bone man empowerment is a sense of
high pergamy within the construct of
body counts loots uh bone man if divorce
race rates increase based on body count
prior to marriage how my men better
secure their future in Offspring
especially when the court side with the
woman when bestowing our public benefit
to the children when those matters are
private in nature barring abuse reclaim
okay I read them all I'm gonna refresh
it really quick also also guys make sure
you like the video how many likes are we
at blessing
2.8 2.8 guys let's try to get can we go
to get what should our goal be by the
end of the stream 3.5 3.5 all right guys
like the video that is the most
important metric that pushes out these
streams so if you're enjoying this
stream make sure you like it a like is
for you guys and send super chats so
blessing can fly out Amber Rose for a
one-on-one interview
um go ahead Auntie describe your perfect
man or what he should have you
oh it's time with me um
perfect man ideally
six two
a bit got a bit of weight to him not not
I can't not too skinny funny humble
loyal
attentive
um
ambitious and he should want me because
I would
reciprocate the same energy
for me the perfect man would be just
taller than me
um
supportive
ambitious loyal
knows what he wants in life takes care
of the family the home
and yeah he should want me because
I have a really big heart
um funny I think in tune with himself
I.E spiritually
um I'm not really bothered about his
heart to be honest he needs to be more
than average downstairs and also know
how to use it and completely obsessed
with me and ambitious
I just wondered when someone's going to
mention sex because women was coming
like
sex is not important I mentioned the
Willie side you're the only one that did
because that matters yeah yeah nobody
mentioned money nobody mentioned a job
and she's the only one that mentioned
and I said I'm ambitious as well so if
he's ambitious he's got pee yeah but he
can be a bin man I want to become a
bigger
real ambition but that is that's what I
mean when women say ambition it could be
a road sweeper and then his ambition is
to drive the truck yeah I hear that no
ambition to be you know have businesses
that are successful and you know become
a millionaire if not billionaire
I feel like it's ambition is ambition
obviously in a perfect world he'd be a
good earner but you have but he needs to
be he needs to enjoy what he does for a
living there's no good someone being
rich and is miserable or is Rich and
does something they don't want to do
just with a sake of making money would
you would you be okay with a guy that's
an artist but makes 10 pounds an hour
and he's happy with it yeah and he's a
really good artist no that's why I said
yes dude you'd have to make a decent
wage me personally if I feel like
salaries is just an important factor you
both have to be heard and you both have
to be bringing something in
would you date someone that makes less
than you
I'm not necessarily I don't mind if it's
less as long as it's not like I'm
carrying
them if they're still able to be
a financial support button this doesn't
bother me how much less could he make
than you
thirty percent twenty percent fifty
percent
I mean it depends on what caliber again
as long as it's not gonna financially
you know what you make I mean I'm not
I'm not gonna ask you to say that but
like what percent less so 20 less than
you 10 percent
um yeah well based on my salary then
yeah I'd say no more than no more than
20 no okay what about you
like for me it's very important for like
my man to take care of the household
like the bills electricity all of that
so it's important I would prefer if he
made more than me okay do you do you
have a cookbook
public recipes that you've made yourself
no okay so why why would he pay a
hundred percent of the bills if you
don't have you know no I didn't say 100
of the bills just mostly takes care of
the bills okay so what percent of the
bills yeah like
60 70 of it seventy percent okay
um obviously I'm an artist so I aspire
to big things like I want to be a
multi-millionaire so I don't expect my
guy to earn that type of money
um but as long as he's he's really
really trying and he's got his [__]
together and it's fine you want to be a
multi-millionaire how old are you 38
when do you expect to be a multi-million
in the next two years in the next two
years how are you gonna do that um
through my music creativity yeah okay
I'm gonna do an album so I just you know
oh yeah yeah at some point yeah oh cool
I just wanted to know how to if you're
gonna do I was like I'll do the same if
you have a plan okay but you what you do
is different to what I do
so what would your album be what would
it consist of I was gonna follow your
plan you're gonna be more okay no don't
follow my plan just do what you want to
do okay okay Auntie do you have any
other questions yeah um
poor man with ambition or rich man with
none
it's a good question
for me it's a rich man with none
because if he's Rich he could we could
be doing other things like going on
holiday creating things and that will
run out if he's got no ambition to make
more money not really because he's not
really he's Rich you can't take that
away from him you can't get it from his
family he's Rich that's what girls
thinking now
it don't change in it he's either Rich
Forever or poor forever that's how it
works so yeah Rich no because it's all
money it can run out if you spend
frivolously and just start doing Madness
he's going to run out I'd rather report
my ambition because at least I know he's
gonna get somewhere because he's
ambitious if you're rich with no
ambition you're just gonna spank it and
you don't aspire to do anything some
people have wealth generational wealth
it depends how rich we're talking it was
like really rich like generational
wealth then I don't see you'd be
surprised a lot of
like I come I come from an area where
like there's a lot of wealthy people and
you'd be surprised how quick they can
blow their kids can blow the money you'd
be surprised
but it's like when we get asked a
question is it body money you can't
change it it's just something that's
always the same if he's rich with no
ambition he's Rich it don't matter it's
just right so as long as you've got the
no Ambush I'm with you so he's got money
and he just doesn't want to do anything
I think she thinks because we've done
sure like we've done question have you
seen a show before no I've talked about
a beam of Kings so oh okay yeah because
King and his show he says it doesn't
switch because like that he has a
different question and it doesn't switch
but I think she's saying it could switch
later you just have to pick one on the
starting point
because I find that you find that with
women they always want somebody who's
made it and I think with men they all
the women want to say that they've made
their money before they meet a man or
they want somebody that's made and I
think the most successful relationships
poor men with ambition where they build
together
because you've both grafted together you
come from nothing I've got something and
I think if you look at most of the rich
couples out there the rich man out there
they're built with their woman from
nothing the ones that have it as well if
you meet someone who's already got it
you're just you're replaceable at this
point yeah because he's got access to
however much because that's what he's
used to when you've built with someone
they're gonna have more value for you
because he was there from the beginning
and grafted with them not to say that
they still won't do so they still won't
leave but they'll have more value for
you I think look at the under 50s out
there that are rich
and look at the ones that have made it
together that are in couples that have
built it from nothing can now get in
there and you see the difference
that's why I asked the question
because a lot of women they want to
either
get they want to get their own
but you want to be a millionaire in two
years
have you got a man now sorry no I'm
single right so when you're a
millionaired then you're gonna get a man
you're gonna get a man before no I'm not
waiting for that like I'm focusing on my
career I've been married I was in a
relationship for 15 years I've got
children so now I need to just focus on
myself and put all my energy into that
whatever comes to me comes to me but I'm
not going to be of a man because of all
his money whatever I'm gonna get my own
which I mean and I would love to share
it with him also I always say that even
if I'm a millionaire I'll give him his
money he still has to pay for the meals
and stuff with regard just because I
like that feeling you miss the chivalry
are emasculating a question what's it
would you say emasculated me yeah or
demasquerade
if you're giving a man money to pay for
your meal that's not demasculating him
how is that that's good man well if he's
got the money and he wants to pay for it
fine if you ain't got it then I'll give
it to you boo we can pretend like who
cares money Shmoney I want to know what
blessings like because he might give a
different
nah that's just crazy sorry
uh if you're gonna give a guy money for
him to pay like yeah but if I'm a
millionaire and you're on a standard
wage I'm paying for everything that just
makes sense so instead of when we go to
a restaurant and I'm pulling out my
credit card you're gonna put out the
credit card don't matter where the
money's coming from but it doesn't feel
like a man though yeah
it's just like when you're in the media
and entertainment money's different you
can have a hit and you're going to get
millions of pounds we're not doing a
normal nine to five it's different it's
a different reality it's a guy just as a
man I'd rather take you to McDonald's
that's called eager and pride yeah and
men have a lot of that I know but babe
you know when you're actually dating a
millionaires it will be a different vibe
in a different language that you're
speaking um
I'll be back here in two years and we'll
have a conversation I have to go boo
because I'm going to miss my my train
I'm really sorry I did actually tell the
staff that I need to leave oh okay sorry
I don't want to leave would you guys
stay if you got if we got your yes okay
that's fine
the stream's doing well but if if you
have to go
that's perfect thank you guys
Super Chat for the Ubers
um what was I gonna ask
would you guys go down in lifestyle for
a family
so say
no Nails no hair very little makeup
budget
but you get a man
for a lifetime loyal he's everything you
want but you have to go down in
lifestyle you maybe get what what's you
pick the amount they get a month for
recreational Auntie's better with the
budgeting recreational for them for the
whole household or just for them for
them I think they get to spend on
themselves everything else is the kids
or the family 500 pound a month 500
pounds a month
no man's perfect but he does everything
that I need him to do yeah but you live
in where do they live auntie I think
Auntie's going to give the better
picture where do they live they live in
kind and a tablet
with tower blocks
yeah so you go from you go from say like
a house a big house in like Primrose
Hill
on your own
to go into a tower Block in Cannon town
with your perfect man and your perfect
family
but in order to do that don't forget
you're building with him
but in order to do that you're not
allowed to no Nails no makeup because
you can't afford it just yet how often
how often can they go out with the girls
information going out with girls no how
often can they go out it could be just
like a dinner or like whatever and a
kind of full dinner you'd invite the
girls in for a night in oh a night and
how often can they do that once a month
once a month yeah so it's either that or
I'm just on my own basis or you go out
with him yeah to be if I'm being
completely honest but he's your perfect
man perfect like you've got two kids
perfect I'll be comfortable like it's
not the kids are paid for it you're the
only thing you can't they can't afford
is you're upkeep
I'd rather I'd rather the family to be
honest family wait so I can't get my
hair done
I just would say what makeup nothing
nothing for how long is that like for as
long as it takes for you to get out of
the kids till the kids are let's say 15.
all right I'll say 15. I'll compromise
13. there's no like divorce inside like
this is my perfect match this is you
know I mean forever man you're still
gonna fight you know a bit you're still
you know human you'll fight you know now
and then but overall a good man
but yeah for 13 years you can you can't
really go out your friends can only come
to you that's really it
I mean I already have my perfect mindset
that mine I don't necessarily need to do
all the hair nails makeup because he's
already dead so I guess I would take the
family and the man yeah
yeah family all day yeah should you wear
makeup for do you make up for yourselves
you do a little bit for yourself or do
you do it to look attractive to men no I
don't do it to attract men or anything I
do it for myself because I do love hair
and makeup and I do love getting my
nails done it just I'm just used to
doing that
you just say yeah
because you wouldn't normally would go
into a club with no makeup on in your
bald head cane Rose No One's Gonna Do it
when you go out yeah you dress yourself
up to attract the opposite sex you do it
to feel good too however you do it for
the up for the opposing person so if
I've already got my man if he accepts me
with no wig no makeup bashes now then
I'm good to be fair yeah exactly that's
basically yeah I have no makeup on my
hair back and stuff like that I've done
it I've done it and I've just done it
because I want to go out and listen to
music I don't care about being
attractive no one because I don't care I
just want to drink and just to enjoy
music
so I've done it but then again I don't
wear makeup
we'll get my nails done
you know what somebody needs to give me
a makeover I want one of them big old
wigs I want to get eyelashes I want to
see how different I look I want makeup I
want to get the nails done what do you
think Pearl give me a on makeover an
auntie makeover yeah and yeah anti-anti
makeover Auntie makeover I think we
could do that when uh yeah when Melanie
King comes to town she could Style Both
of Us yeah something
yeah
do you think people do you think
everyone
um
this is another thing I got in trouble
for
they come for me for no reason really
honestly so do you think everyone
deserves love
no no
yeah you think everyone deserves love
yeah
what about
Hitler
uh he's going in Phase that on your
mother could love
his own family would have that he would
have love for his own family that's it
but he doesn't deserve love from like
anyone else do you think yeah everyone
deserves love
I mean some people deserve to be
tolerated some people deserve to be
liked but not everybody deserves to be
loved okay so we think that they don't
do you think they had love in their life
though Hitler had someone Jeffrey had
somebody regardless everybody no but
they still had it but it's not designed
they had it but they didn't deserve it
it could be sick love you don't think
love is earned
um life should be young depending on who
it comes from it should be unconditional
like a mother and child it should be
unconditional love you shouldn't have to
earn your parents love I think I think
that you're I think children deserve
love but I don't think adults deserve
love
why not I think everyone deserves to
know what love feels like unconditional
she means
adults don't you you could love somebody
but you may not like them which you know
what I mean and I think that's a
difference I think a love is an
extremely strong emotion that we kind of
underwrite because you can be in we've
done it I'm sure you know I've been in a
relationships like I shouldn't have
loved that person but I did because it's
it's an emotion that's created you know
what I'm saying it's not earned you
create love you said you can love
someone but not necessarily like them
yeah I think the other way around so you
could like somebody but not love them
yeah I tend to that's easy I tend to
dislike anybody but save the love for
special people but some people like
certain family like parents for example
um I love my dad because he's my dad but
I don't like him as a person you can
love someone
but not necessarily like the person that
they are now you just say I like him
because he's my dad's and that's what
society says no but I love him because
of certain there's certain memories and
stuff you have with that with particular
people about my parents I like my dad
because he's my dad
that's it
Nelson he's a bad dad but just that I
love my grandchildren
that's it love is a sick thing as well
like I think love is just so complex do
I mean because it's like let's stay away
from the family love because that's like
easy let's stick to the kind of romantic
love
I mean I I don't know why for some
reason I've just got like pimp and [__]
in my head I don't know why but it's
like these men you know abuse these
women but they fall in love I don't know
it's so strange like like I said love is
it's sickening you can't sometimes you
can't work out you can't comprehend it
with the minds it is literally an energy
or an emotion so it's not infatuation or
something it could be
is it infatuation is that love
um
what's that is that Stockholm Stockholm
syndrome yeah when you love your captor
yeah just love comes in many shapes and
forms me like we'll all sit here as
different people that's the mental
illness isn't it Stockholm syndrome
that's meant all love so okay it's love
in the mind or is it in the body the
women had to do that because before what
would they do they would kill if one
tribe overtook another tribe they would
kill the children and the men and take
the women so like women had to Evolution
it like if they wanted to pass on their
genes they had to fall in love with
their Captor it's like a coping
mechanism essentially I don't know
it's like arranged marriages also I
don't know if that's the same thing
I think it's about it's like lions and
the Cubs you know when when the tribes
take over and then you say arrange
marriages all kinds of because some of
those people in their cultures they
don't have a choice like whoever they're
given to that's who they and it's still
real to this day that's that's not
that's not what arranged marriages are
like what is it what is it like they
have a choice they get the people and
they actually have a choice okay it's
not like this is a person you're gonna
marry him they say this is what we're
looking for in a man that's what we're
looking for in a woman and the families
talk and eventually they meet and if
they don't like each other they say I
don't like them and then they go and
choose again I don't know I think in
some countries
um maybe not so much here but in some
countries I think that they don't have a
choice these young girls that are given
to these older men I don't think they
have a choice when the family sell them
for money and stuff
personally I think that definitely does
exist that's an exception but that's not
that's not what amber Hayes marriages
actually are that's abuse would you guys
consider yourself modern or traditional
modern women are traditional women
um
identify falling there's I still have a
lot of traditional
um values but I also
do have a lot of modern takes on things
so I don't I don't think I fall into
either bracket to be fair could you tell
me how are you modern how are you
traditional so like what Traditional
Values do you have and like what about
you is modern
um traditional in a sense of I feel like
um women should
take care of house and home and I feel
like men should be providers of a
household
um
however I do also feel like in this day
and age
I'm not I don't really like calling
people [__] or [__] or any other
things like that like if you wanna
whoever you want to see maybe who you
want to sleep with like it doesn't so
you're more modern because you're not
judgmental yeah essentially okay but you
do believe in women taking care of the
home and men going to off to work
basically no definitely I feel like
women I feel like it's as women you
should know to cook food you should know
how to clean a house you should know how
to just those basic things I think
that's forgotten a lot in this in this
day and age women don't know how to cook
food or just they'll know how to drink
and go out partying but don't know how
to season food or green chicken or
anything like that I think that needs
that's not something that's as common
anymore
for me I'd say I'm more traditional I
would only say a modern in the sense of
I don't like to judge people
but I'm definitely more traditional in
the sense of like you know
keeping yourself to marriage taking care
of the household the children letting
the man be the brain like um The
Breadwinner and things like that
um so yeah what traditional skills do
you have
um can you sell uh yeah I can actually
say you can sell yeah I learned how to
sew when I was a kid so what else I
clean the house I cook
um yeah just take care of the home
really like I'm always cleaning at home
so are you a virgin
no no not that one okay go ahead okay if
we're gonna go traditional okay go ahead
I think when it comes to matters of the
heart I'm more traditional
um what makes me a modern woman is the
fact that I'm you know pursuing a career
basically without relying on a guy
so you would
pick one
traditional you're a traditional woman
okay yeah team I'm a traditionalist
with modern gadgets
[Laughter]
so yeah I'm not traditional I'm not
modern I'm this a traditionalist
I tender
like the traditional stuff
I tend to try and follow that way they
want to know in the chat what cultural
dishes
um because everyone said they could cook
what cultural dishes can you cook
um Frosty chicken rice Kali curry
chicken roti
dalidian okay what traditional or what
um cultural dishes can you cook well I'm
Congolese so I'll make rice and pundu at
home and for the Congolese people
they'll know okay what else what else
um well a lot of Congolese is like
fondue Madison I'm not sure a lot of
people know about that unless you're
congrelease yourself
um yeah it's a little right the rice
dishes are also like a lot of pasta
dishes
um yeah but okay what about you um so my
Heritage is Jamaican and British
um but my ex-husband was Colombian so I
learned a lot how to infuse so anything
from scratch really whether that's a
fried English breakfast or a pasta meal
or a chicken stew or you know any of
anything from scratch is love and
passion do you think traditional women
are virgins foreign
if you're going to use if you're going
to take the word as it is then yeah yeah
no I'm not I don't think so no no what
do you think Katie I've been a
traditional word for traditional women
is Virgin I think that traditional women
are virgins I'll tell you why because
traditional is putting the family before
yourself right and I think the most if
we're gonna like do the archetype of
like ideal traditional women they're
thinking about the family from the time
they're like 12 13 14 so they don't want
to have sex with anyone else because
other than their husband
because they don't want to bring that
into a marriage so if we're going to do
like the ideal archetype of like what is
the ideal traditional woman I I would
argue it's probably a virgin
I agree because they're they're thinking
Family First from like a very young age
they would never get divorced
um career really isn't first for that
like it's always family before career
everything's Family First
is there anything else you guys would
add to that that I missed
as far as being traditional yeah
I think like her attitude as well
towards her man um
yeah that's a good one then trying to
dominate or be in control or even be
equal is that yeah it's about being able
to submit to your man your husband okay
it's sex on tap
I think that sits on tap when he wants
it as much as possible I think that's
what a lot of women will struggle with
what do you struggle with
can traditional women cheat ever no if
they're traditional then I no no
yeah they're not gonna know about it
you think a traditional woman can cheat
yeah she can take care of the home and
do her future wants an um who knows
what's going on behind closed doors you
just never know no I don't think
anyone's perfect you just never know
she can do she could be all those things
and cheat but how can a traditional
woman be a virgin if she's got a family
that's what it doesn't I meant like a
virgin on her wedding night okay
what do you think Auntie wow that's what
I'm thinking man she said about cheating
oh wow no I don't think just because she
could I don't think she should and I
think traditionally they wouldn't
what percent of women do you think want
to be wives and what percent of women do
you think are happy being single in
today's day and age yeah and by by happy
being single means single today happy
for life being single
I think a lot more women are happy being
single nowadays
um
I'd say maybe
40 of women prefer being single 40 I
think so today's day and age and they
would rather be single than with a man
they respect and admire
okay maybe not for like 30. I feel like
a lot more women now would rather I know
a lot of women that value their career
over relationships I know a lot of women
that have not got into relationships
because they're so career driven I think
it happens more in this day and age I'd
say about yeah 30 to 40 percent okay
what do you think I'll say 20 20 and 80
want to be in relationships what do you
think
um I think if everybody's actually
really honest with themselves I think
100 percent
like you don't who wants to be single
for the rest of their lives that's just
dead if you can find a guy that you can
look here will look you in your eyes and
actually say you know what I love you
and I want you to be my wife I want to
cherish you forever every woman would
lap that up unless she's a lesbian
what do you think are valid reasons for
divorce
um
consistent genuing
consistent cheating domestic abuse all
right so I'm gonna make a list
consistent cheating
domestic abuse what else
um drug abuse I think a master confused
drug abuse
okay what else anything else nice
lies
okay
how many lies just one I just don't like
lies tell me when I'm out of there
okay consistent cheating domestic abuse
drugs drug abuse and lies anything else
he's if he's a psychopath like certain
mental
yeah mental illnesses I think definitely
could could divorce someone or um poor
financial
what's what I'm looking for
like gambling
gambling yeah or like they have they
don't know they can't on addiction yeah
an unhealthy addiction yeah but also one
yeah yeah in an overall
you know that question you asked Pearl
about being happy being single
I think that if you
broke it into age groups it would sound
it'd be different
but if you do like
I say like the 30s and under and the 30s
over or 40s and under you might find
there's more unhappy women
or more women that want to get married
the older they get when they're young
they're happy being single it's only
when they're old and washed up that they
realize that oh [__] I should have had a
man back then I still would have been
with him so I think you might find that
if you'd put an age group on it the
answers would have been different do you
think a lot of women Auntie regret
leaving their husbands in hindsight
I'll say about 75 percent do really yeah
three out of four you would say regret
it why do they regret it later because
they've just done it there was no valid
reason they did it because they could or
because they didn't feel right or they
get bored or he wasn't paying attention
to me off at once is if it's like if
somebody's life is in danger then you've
got a good reason and if there's not
then you haven't that's my view so if
you're alive for your children's life or
somebody's life is not in danger then
you've got no reason to get divorced
foreign
to everything else other than can be
worked on
I mean when you think about it if you
can get divorced for I was thinking
about this the other day if you can get
divorced for pretty much any reason like
not being happy not feeling fulfilled
he's not paying attention to me he's
never home like then why not just be in
a relationship what's the difference
like because if you're married it's
supposed to be for richer for poorer
through thick and then it's like you're
supposed to everything but like
especially went through that yeah I
think the Catholic church is like abuse
addiction like there's or if you know
there's some secret he was hiding that
you didn't know but when you got married
but
otherwise I mean just being a
relationship like why even get married
then
um it depends on what what section
you're talking about I think I'm sure
monogamy is supposed to be a part of
marriage so I feel like if we've decided
to make
um if you decide to get married and tie
yourself for life
I shouldn't have to accept you
consistently stepping out of the
household
um and have to deal with that throughout
a marriage yeah but I think you should
vet that before you get married yeah but
I feel like this is a nice and unspoken
rule like no one it's everyone knows
you're not supposed to cheat in a
relationship or any committed situation
unless you've decided to have an open
relationship you know when I think of
traditional women there's there's a
certain woman that and I've told this
story so many times on the pods they're
gonna but it's fine I I think of there's
there's a woman I know she's a relative
she's Catholic okay
she did not believe in divorce she would
rather die like that's when you really
meet someone with a truly traditional
mindset they would rather die than get
divorced like that there's nothing you
could tell her
and her husband
um they lived in Wisconsin and then her
husband like kind of went back and forth
he worked in Chicago he had a side chick
in Chicago like a whole girlfriend in
Chicago okay
and
that that woman she was she was Catholic
and she she like all she prayed to God
she said God please find a way to keep
my family together he left he left the
family all right for the side chick and
she prayed to God please find a solution
help us get back together
and the side chick died
amen
and he came home
and they stayed married and they never
got divorced and when I think of
traditional women that's who I think of
because she would rather die than leave
her man and like how many women have
that mindset of like
she didn't get mad that he cheated she
didn't throw it in his face she didn't
get angry over it and always bring it
back up later she genuinely tried to
find a solution understood where he was
coming from and wanted to keep the
family together no matter what now I'm
not saying you know they had a perfect
marriage or We should strive for that
but I just think like that mentality is
so rare nowadays it's like it's like
they see Instagram and they think
something's going to be better on the
other side and a lot of times it's not
sometimes from the where we're sitting
now the coach is here we must know some
old person
that's done that because I know a couple
and I actually know that this this guy
and I always saw him with his wife
and um together and I think I said oh
he's gone somebody said where's he gone
I said oh
so where's your husband assistant
where's your husband that's not my
husband
I was just like okay I said someone
what's their problem I said she got
everybody said that's not us that's my
husband that's not his wife so what do
you mean they're always together he's
got doggies goes to the house we've all
up into the house you know he's like
another home and then I met the wife
the wife knew all about it but that was
her husband and if the wife steps in and
if they happen to meet that's okay we're
going to a funeral and the wife was
there
she had to step back and hold her place
and because the wife was the wife she
didn't they all had basically Separate
Lives you know the wife's still got the
family home grandkids and everything and
he goes and comes but their wife's got
up they always have to show respect
because she's the wife and there's no
way on Earth that she'd ever give him a
divorce
that's her husband her house her
whatever he does outside but he's there
for his grandkids he's there for the
things that husband's supposed to do
but just because something's a tradition
does that mean it should be uphold
forever just because it's a tradition I
believe in death to us part I believe
that if I got married somebody has to
die
I'm a firm believer in that and I that's
my husband if you if I was married and
you want to step out you can step out
and step in as much as like at the end
of the day
I'm I'm not I'm not getting divorced I
mean do you think it's wise to do what's
worked or try something new
um I don't think worked is the right
terminology though I feel I feel like
the word is
um
tolerated I feel like there's a lot of
tolerating going on because something's
a tradition I don't necessarily think
it's worked because back in back in the
day like my grandparents for example it
was the same concept there was no such
thing as divorce and I know I know
certain couples go through
disrespect and a lot of abuse and a lot
of bad things but you tolerate it
because you don't get divorced I feel
like at some point you have to break
that barrier of okay so you're not
you're not respecting me as an
individual or as the mother of your
children or as your wife but I must deal
with this because we got married
what's better for the children separate
households or one household if if it's a
toxic household and there's abuse going
on separate because children what's
better figuring out how to get along or
continuing to be toxic it takes two to
be toxic 100 but sometimes there isn't
there is no repair sometimes things are
Beyond repair I I think that's a choice
you can't if someone's screaming at you
and argue it's your choice to scream
back a hundred percent but you can also
fall out of love with someone based on
repeated Behavior someone might not
adapt or someone is compromise it has to
go this way is love a feeling or a
choice
loves the feeling
you think so yeah I feel like you can't
so because sometimes you don't want to
love someone but you do if it was a
choice you would decide I don't love you
anymore but it's not always that simple
do you think your your parents always
felt like they loved you
like when like I don't know when I was a
kid there was times I would scream out
of temper tantrums you think my mom in
that moment
just felt love for me
deep deep down yeah but I have a face
money she used to beat me with a spoon
but out of love it was out of love
though yeah but that's what I mean like
she might not have felt like she loved
me but her choices proved that she did
and I think it's the same thing with a
family like I mean in my opinion anyway
I think you know you can feel a certain
way about your husband you might hate
him at some even what if Michelle Obama
came out and said she hated Barack for
10 years okay so in a situation where
you've got a husband and a wife and the
husband goes out and he goes to work and
he provides for the family however he
comes home every night and he beats his
wife and then he beats his kids so
should that woman deal with that and
tolerate that for the rest of her life
because she decided to get married don't
forget I said what says now once
nobody's life's in danger okay
it's really interesting like women
always bring up abuse like we're just
getting beat left and right hmm when the
numbers don't show that the majority of
men are abusing women so that you know
that's not that's an exception it's not
the rule
um yeah I think if your life's in danger
I would agree but I actually would still
um
part of me like I the part of me still
thinks that you should separate not
divorce
so so then was I don't know but I'm not
gonna die on that Hill I haven't thought
that one like don't don't quote me okay
it's like I'm gonna say that for now I
might change my mind later okay
but
it's a paper it's a piece of paper as
well I know isn't it marriage like I
think
now it is I think yeah because
everything that you say in your vows
um you know loving whatever whatever
that's that's someone's actions getting
divorced is it's the paper it's the
legal whatever that word is yeah where a
relationship is something you have to
work on like most people that get
divorced they usually have some form of
relationship sometimes another the love
doesn't die it just evolves somewhere
different like I'm divorced I got
married I was with my um ex-husband for
15 years from 17 onwards and then we got
married in the last year I proposed to
him just because I thought it was the
right thing to do
um and then we we broke up and we don't
really talk we've got a terrible
relationship so you waited 16 years to
get married 15 years yeah 15 years yeah
then you got married
and then you broke up divorced after
yeah yeah because we shouldn't have got
married we were trying to do the right
thing for our children
um but you know we just grew apart as
people it wasn't for any real reason I
grew apart couldn't you grow back
together I know because if you grew one
way you could grow the other one well
the thing is Boo like I was 17 when I
got with him I was a child which I mean
that was a 38 year old woman I don't
feel any form of attraction to him at
all the way he talks walks dresses his
whole thing with two completely
different people so you left because you
weren't attracted to him no we left
because we're just two different people
on two different paths because I'm just
thinking I might like my mom met my dad
when she was 17 and I mean there were
times where they didn't like each other
and she probably like you know would
have said the same thing at one at some
points in their marriage but they just
stuck it out and like and now they're
really cute my dad just took her on the
cutest thing because they're getting old
I just wanted to know because I don't
believe that women should ask men yeah I
think that's just the Daniel as well
yeah why did you ask him everything
because I find that if a man's gonna
marry he's going to be like yes within
the first say three four years after
that it's just because he feels
pressurized by Society we've got kids or
the woman said we've been together for
how many years now you're gonna make an
honest woman of me and yeah no it's a
big mistake personally like I don't
think any woman should propose to a man
I think a man should take his wife and
that's the first mistake to make
um and also just trying to for me I
wanted him to feel secure in our
relationship because I've always been
quiet not always but I was a little bit
more bigger energy than him and he was a
little he's a Colombian man you know
they think
and I'm a British kind of I was right my
mom was single like was raised to be
ourselves really hard and I'm a creative
so there's all these culture clashes as
well
um but yeah you know I think personally
not everything is about marriage like we
got together when we was children we
don't know ourselves I didn't know
myself as a woman he didn't know himself
as a man so after those years we're
still what 21-22 we had our first child
we're trying to open up a business like
it weren't a factor of you know um
where it needs to be is something that
kind of felt natural but it wasn't if
you didn't get married would you still
being together no no
the vibe just changed the energy just
changes you want different things from
different people like he's happy to have
a nine to five I don't want that women
always seems to outgrow the men
especially the artists especially the
artists that even book writers musicians
painters or something like that they
move in a different Circle and then all
of a sudden like they're there and and
they see the land is there it's not on
my level anymore or they've outgrown him
or he doesn't understand me I'm mixing
in different circles I've got different
Vibes yeah it wasn't that but I I
respect did you feel like that that he
was holding back your career at all yeah
a thousand percent like you know I
remember I had a major audition he said
if you go for that me and you're
breaking up and that's the audition for
big brother and I got three Big
Brother's like you don't know it's a
reality show it's a reality show and
people about 10 people going to a house
and they get watched 24 7 whatever and I
got through quite far and he's like if
you go on it then basically it's either
me or the show obviously is it a dating
show no it's just it's like a social
experiment where they put like 12
different people different personalities
into one house for three months
yeah yeah it's hilarious it's cool
um so yeah and you know he always oh
you're an attention seeker this year
that like he was putting me down from a
young age and not appreciating and
respecting who I was as a person
um but that was his own insecurities
because as much as yeah I'm an artist
and flamboyant and I'm also a loyal
woman I I appreciate and love loyalty
and respect and sacredness and the fact
that I could go out and you know
perform but then come home to my husband
would have been a dream come true for me
but his own ego for whatever reasons
wherever he's come from his environment
he didn't allow it
if he didn't do that would you do you
think it would have worked out 100 yeah
if he would have appreciated me for who
I was as a person so it sounds like he
wanted you to act more traditional in a
way and yeah you were more modern yeah
and then that's what ended the marriage
was he was trying to make you into
something that you're not basically so
I'm not a traditional woman this is what
I've realized this is the conversation
I'm a modern woman so yeah that was the
reason he just realized that
as you're not talking
in a minute I was just waiting for the
pain
depending with my husband still to this
day if I was a traditional woman
whenever women say Traditional Values
they always say cooking feeling looking
after those and men can do that easy
whenever they say Traditional Values and
we get to hear something that men agree
on and
we always say cooking cleaning looking
out for the kids everyone just want
someone to have his back and to enhance
him
that's it enhance him grow with him
that's it
but I was glad that you realized that
you weren't traditional because the way
you were saying because
you know when I realized is when you
said oh he said if I was going to go on
Big Brother hmm
that was finished and I wouldn't but I
didn't go on Big Brother
I missed the opportunity like oh you
listened to him yeah of course I did oh
right yeah if you didn't end up getting
remarried do you think you would regret
it
said it again babe if you didn't end up
getting remarried so if you're if you're
70 60 by yourself would you regret
leaving him yeah because my next part
that I'm with we don't actually
physically have to get married if he
marries himself to me and we're loyal
when we live that way cool but we don't
have to go to a church or go to a
registry office and sign the papers for
the government no but I want to find my
man that's loyal to me I'm loyal to him
that I can give myself to that's what I
want no but I'm saying like if that
didn't happen would you because we were
talking about earlier that a lot of
women regret it because they don't end
up fine I'm not saying that'll help me
I'm just saying if if you were in that
situation do you think you'd regret it
yeah well I'm hoping I don't stay single
for the rest of my life
um yeah because I don't hate the guy I
think if you put in if you put an effort
into anything anything could work out so
I mean I actually I still love the guy
so so in a way did you feel like you
could do better than that relationship a
thousand percent but that's only because
I got into a relationship as a child as
a teenager and not as a woman that knows
herself off and 17's and I don't I don't
think 17 is an adult not at all 17 is an
adult all depends on your mindset
exactly my son at 17. and I'll be I had
to be an adult so if I was with a man
and get in a relationship you'd have to
be an adult we played the adults played
yeah that's what I mean yeah okay that I
didn't play yeah we had the household we
had the children we did we was doing the
whole thing you know what I'm saying but
at the same time I was a child because
I'm emotionally unintelligent so when
the The War of the World actually do
start to come up to you you don't know
how to deal with them properly and
that's my own experience but didn't your
mum help you
um well my mum's come from relationship
after relationship come from a broken
family so I've had to break the
generational curse even I'm not with him
but I'm not out here sleeping with Tom
Dick and Harry I'm celibate like I'm
holding myself down because I don't need
to be doing casual sex and I'm waiting
for my king so in order to wait for my
king I have to hold myself
do you think that men generally want to
wait for women that have had children
already because I've just talked to guys
about this and it's kind of like if you
already have a child no they don't yeah
or they don't like do you think that's a
good strategy no the men don't want
women that have got children
unfortunately because the thought of it
bringing up someone's kid or whatever
but my children they're not children
they're young men no I meant the
celibacy like it sounded like you were
gonna have guys like wait for sex
because you don't own it okay so no
they're not waiting I'm waiting so I'm
not in I'm not in any form of
relationship like I don't even think
you're focused on the career yeah and
myself though because I don't I don't
like to just let any guy inside of me
because that don't make me feel good so
it's not just about the career because
I'm still I'm single I want a man I want
someone to cause a lot with I want to
have sex I want to have a connection but
I'm not just gonna do it just because
I'd rather hold out I'd rather be in
agony and black I can you know
not the right guy but you know how how
long ago was the divorce
um it was like
six years ago now do you think it could
ever be reconciled no he just had a baby
oh bless him like he's got a woman and
like no it doesn't I wish that we could
have a good relationship because we're
family we've got children together I
wish we could go out for meals together
and talk and communicate and have a
healthy relationship but I think that's
not gonna happen because he still has
feelings towards me I've got feelings
for him but not in that way ju so it's
it's awkward so he he has another woman
but he's still he's still a thousand
percent so what does he say he wants to
get back with you we don't talk we don't
talk the last kind of conversation that
we had I he made certain energy clear
that there was still something there and
I don't respect that so if you can't
treat me you know we're not but that's
meant for you so you have to put the
boundary how long ago was that and that
was about
two years ago so you haven't spoken in
two years no do you think maybe he
doesn't have the same feelings now that
he's just had the kid I would love that
if that was the case but then we would
be able to have a healthy relationship
isn't it if there was no feelings there
so it's just how it is the kids don't
you guys have to communicate to her
um well my children are grown now and
when we when we divorced how old is your
youngest 15 okay he doesn't go to his
dad's yeah he goes to his dad's they see
each other they've got a healthy
relationship my children have got but
relationships with both of us and we
communicate very clearly with them so
like I said because I'm a young mom
um and I've experienced coming from a
broken home I made sure my children
didn't go through that so I always speak
to my children communicate look me and
Dad not together but you know we still
care about you you can have two
different lives two different homes they
stay there stay at my house it's it's
healthy it's unfortunate but it is what
it is Young mum yeah is it hard ever
like around the holidays like having I'm
assuming you go switch up
so basically every other so this next
year I'm gonna have them Christmas he
has some New Year's vice versa um you
just do it that way is is that hard or
is that okay no it's lovely because that
means that we both get to do our own
thing every other time and I think it's
great
one question popped up in my head at
what age do you expect to stop having
sex
all of you never until my body's broken
okay
that's an interesting question
I mean I don't think I can put an age on
it okay just until your buddies
basically just can't physically do it
anymore
yeah I agree no there isn't a number I
just wondered because some people have
numbers and I think we've got a number
so I just want to see if anybody only
had an actual number because as far as
I'm concerned there is no number how
long do you think women should wait
before having sex with a new guy
for me it's about commitment because I
until we are committed to each other
that's no matter how long that takes
until he's in a relationship with you
yeah but where I'm at right now most
likely until we're married
okay so you want to be celibate until
you're married yeah so where am I where
I am in my life right now yes do you do
you think that's fair to ask of a guy if
the last guy didn't have to do that
um not necessarily that's not fair no
ways and he's not unfair it's not unfair
to him
I'm just I'm just going to give you I'm
gonna do this blessing do you think
that's unfair
hell yeah
blessing How would how would that go
over for you if a girl asks you to wait
when she does she's not a virgin I'm
good listen think about listen listen I
know what she's gonna say that was
before she was a Christian she's a
Christian and she's in church
would you wait if he was a church man no
if he was a church man no I mean he goes
to church every Sunday I mean committed
he knows what I mean once you've opened
the game
okay
um how long do you wait do you think do
you think girls should wait good you
could say how long you think girls
should wait it's gonna be a
controversial opinion but
I think it depends on the situation
because you could be in a situation
where you hold out then I think girls
hold out because it's off the basis they
think men respect them more if they hold
out but you can hold out have sex with
someone and then they're like they'll
they're on to the next you don't think
it matters how long you wait
um I don't think not on the first not on
the first date I don't think he should
it it happens but I feel like at least
the first date you can kind of hold it
out
um
a baby like third date I would say
roughly third date yeah how long would
you have known him from the first to the
third date like how long does that take
usually
um before I go on a date I need to speak
to them for a bit so you're talking
maybe like two three week speaking
period there may be a date a week so so
like three three weeks roughly a month
that's a lot of money I will date a week
no like on by the third date I mean so
you go first date one week then second
date the week after then the third date
the week after that he's paying for
these dates
um it depends I think if he says to me I
want to take you for dinner that first
day he should be paying then after that
it's like 50 50.
um yeah okay
what do you think Hmm how long
like it's all about energy because the
body is the body and Science and
hormones and chemistry and
stuff like that so I think it's when you
feel comfortable with that person for me
I know that I want to be exclusive and
it needs to be a commitment that I'm not
going to be having sex with somebody
that's having sex with other women
um so yeah I think I just need to go
over my instincts to be honest but it
definitely won't be on the first date
or the second date like it
Fifth Third
um I'll be honest I don't date like I
haven't even ever done that I've always
known somebody and then moving Oh you
mean they're like friends yeah like or
you know them in some form of way like I
won't just meet us like somebody so you
meet you know let's say
and my my producer has a girlfriend but
let's just pretend there's another one
there he's single you just meet through
friends right yeah yeah so then how long
um you know he's not a serial killer he
knows a couple people you know yeah it
needs a time and he's so many of these a
few weeks okay a few weeks yeah okay
okay Auntie how long
I know it's been a while since you've
been in the dating game but
I think nowadays it's like
as soon as
you want nowadays because I found out
that dates will involve sex in my day
I've been I've been seeing guys for like
a year and never had sex with them we
just got friends chill out go out
together in groups and single
and then you think nah they wanna well
then you might think yeah then after you
think now but
I think as long as it takes but if I
knew them what I knew now
lock it down from the beginning
I just wait till I'm a virgin and
because I was really unattractive I'll
be the oldest virgin girl auntie auntie
if they're not virgins how long if
they're not virgins yeah we're all free
up free it up
three four three so they're doing now
yeah that's what these dating sites are
in it you'll you'll like linking people
oh no I'm not talking like that I'm
talking about like meeting somebody for
I don't believe in dating sites I'm
talking about you meet someone you can
psych them out you you know where
they're coming from because you never
just go and pick up someone and go on a
date you're gonna know them from before
so nowadays if you're single you've got
no kids and you want to free it up free
up you want to be slight go ahead free
up if not just don't blessing guys point
of view how long should women wait
how many hours
how many how many days how many dates
roughly dates yeah date
one
okay if it was my sister she can wait a
long time
but ain't no these girls they have to
give it up
yeah let me tell you is if you're not
doing it someone else is doing it hope
you're not doing that somebody else is
for your sister how long can she wait
does she have to wait so she's married
yeah she can wait forever
[Music]
any more questions
at what age did you use your virginity
16.
no comment
yeah I'm gonna say no comment as well
I use I was young though I wouldn't want
my daughter to lose her virginity that
young and I was extremely promiscuous as
well at a very young age
um but obviously I I believe in
different things I believe in certain
influences
whether that be your environment
spiritual whatever but what I know is
that I'm learning from my mistakes and
if I had a daughter
um I would teach her certain things I
feel I feel like I personally was left
to just grow instead of having a woman
and a I didn't have my dad or my mom
there to guide me I was observing my mom
having you know I'm not gonna expose
something I grew up around people right
with mums and dads yeah and it's only
when I was an adult I realized that all
my friends I was playing with were
actually out there having sex and I was
like but we were at school that was like
yeah we would have it and I just I just
couldn't believe it but it was out then
there's people out there having sex
well I know is that my son he's 17 now
but he broke his virginity when he was
16 which I'm happy about I wish he would
have left it longer but whatever and
then my 15 year old he's still a virgin
so we're good for now
I'm gonna look at my grandchildren my
grandchildren having no sex until I say
oh my gosh I found out
on sneaker stream that my sister had had
sex I was like
I was like gas
like no
hello sister because someone said like
what's her body count in the comments
and I I was like don't answer that and
then and then I was thinking she was a
virgin then sneako away and they had a
way of going around the question and
then she was like one and I was like
no
and she's quite old compared to the
girls nowadays yeah I know she is older
yeah like but yeah yeah I was like
um okay you got any more Auntie how many
kids are you so funny gonna have
I don't know if you've got any unless
she is but how many do you want and by
what age do you want to have all of them
um I want to have four
and latest maybe like 38.39
I want to have three and latest
28 29
I would like to have one more little
girl
um star but I need to have certain
things in place
and now I was gonna say how do you know
you're gonna have a girl but then you're
gonna tell me Oh I thought he's gonna
tell me that you're going to connect the
stars and make sure it is
and then you know until my body's the
right temperature to his and then we're
gonna produce this girl that's what I
was waiting for what age would you guys
like to start having kids and would you
have to be married to have a child
say I would have to be married 100
um
because I was raised by a single mother
and I saw how hard it was for her so I
don't want that for myself
um but definitely like 26 27 okay but at
the same time it just depends on my
circumstances as well
um but I'll definitely have to be
married yeah what about you
um I'd prefer to be married it's not
really a deal breaker for me
um but I don't I don't think I'm ready
to have my first child at least until
I'm about
29 30 29 30. yeah okay what about you
um both my children were planned so I
had my first child when I was 20 and
then the next one I was 22 because I
wanted to be a young mom and grow with
them and be youthful and stuff but I
just I don't know it's all about your
maturity I suppose and I think that your
your financial situation definitely
needs to be fought about as well
okay so what age would you want to have
your next oh the next one okay so I'm 39
like if I'm gonna have another child it
needs to be in the next like five years
if I haven't got another charge in the
next five years but I'm not gonna say oh
I can't have any more children because
if I'm having sex with my man
unprotectedly my my guy and and we have
a baby that's God's will that what am I
supposed to
so yeah you just kind of shoot up see
what happens
you know once I've got those Millions
yeah
I know a woman she had a baby and she
was in the early 50s 60s and she had it
naturally yeah totally unexpected
they're having a baby's not a promise
but it's like what happens the next
decade you're going to be 60 you're
doing school around there's that's what
I think about as well
you know it's not just about if your
body can carry it because having to say
that when you go into if you take your
church at the age if you take your child
into the school and you're going to be
looked at as a grandparent or the great
grandparent well they say oh here's your
granny no that's my mom yeah and people
need to think about having children like
because I knew a woman and she had a
child late and it's only and I got
married and left that a daughter told
her how scared she was all of her life
their mom was gonna die exactly because
her mama does so out and she really
thought yeah growing up and their mum
didn't know that it's not nice
[Music]
do you have any warranty how many are
you good enough bro what how many kids
you're good enough
come on I want to be good mother
um
he's gonna try and beat your dad's mom
and dad's records no I mean I think
maybe if I started younger yeah like I
could have had more but no I probably
want four kids I think okay
fours I really liked when my family was
around four I thought six it gets kind
of hectic but like four or five is like
nice
um
yeah six was a lot that was a lot in the
house at the same time there was always
someone screaming but it was really fun
too so that's why he's being part of a
big family I hated it really I always
wanted to be a nouny child I loved it
they were too noisy too boisterous too
[__] I hated it yeah but see it's
interesting because we have different
experiences
no even growing up I was just the weird
one I just like quiet libraries books
and they like music boys you know
dancing TV and movies and the hate
watching movies and stuff like that so I
never fitted in I used to tell people
that they handed the wrong child at the
hospital that was my excuse why are you
like them oh I'm just different I think
they handed the wrong child at the
hospital would you guys ever adopt yeah
I haven't really thought of it but
maybe maybe I would adopt inside the
family not out I fostered
and now I think I'd adopt inside the
family
I I wouldn't adopt outside the family
adoption comes with a lot of issues that
people don't really think about so I
don't
and because I've got no other children
around but I find it
I've fostered when my son was young and
he always had children around and it's
you it's a balance
you know you've got to balance it with
your children that child and how your
child feels so I think adoption is just
if it's a family member or a close
friend and they die they're from a good
parent to someone and they die fine but
either that or if I get if I meet a
younger man and I can't have a child if
I get a younger man now if I wanted a
child but no definitely adopt family I
wouldn't mind adopting I actually had a
dream that I adopted this little girl
the other day she's three months no
she's three months old but she had a big
like Bob and she could speak fluent like
literally but I think some people they
need you know we need to adopt each
other in a certain way and especially if
you've got the the means to do it and
the love why not like it's all about
relationship that's the most important
thing communication and relationship
um okay I'm gonna Read Super chats
really quick and then I think we're
going to close out the show
um guys make sure you like the video
that is the most important metric that
YouTube uses to push out these live
streams so make sure that you like it
also guys um if you have topics or
questions that you want me to ask the
next panel send them to me on Instagram
just pearly things one that's just
pearly things one
okay the real csmo you don't need
emotional intelligence to choose right
or left I wish people would stop asking
women to Define that phrase SM start
asking women to Define that phrase SMH
Manny F which version version of Thor
would you prefer pre-end game or post
endgame hey you a divorced marriage
equals a broken home even if the parents
are cordial and involved
Nicole Lewis marriage is a contract a
series of promises you make
to the other person you have children
vows to one another when you break up a
marriage for personal game you're
choosing yourself over your family
um you are choosing yourself over your
bows and family bone man 538 so they are
no longer two but one flash therefore
God has joined together let not let's
not separate man Joseph I super chatted
for the Reds Uber but she's still there
I take my money back also free the Tates
boneman 538 marriage isn't always a
piece of paper um that is a marriage
license which is from the courts
licensing what otherwise would be
illegal lawful marriage equals sixth
month cohabitating um the center of my
world Pearl lookup dating and marriage
living free
um a scout and Bradley sad truth more
men sad truth is that more men are more
loyal than women for marriage nowadays
to Queen Hilton the couch is tolerating
her weight black is Panther I think men
should be faithful if they take a vow
however if a woman ever denies her
husband's sex even once he has the
permission to step out to Queen Hilton
overeating in Wings should be grounds
for divorce bone man 538 if the man wins
gambling you'd be all up in the grill
sounds like conditional love which is
equivalent to hell what is unconditional
love within the context of a marriage
look like to Queen being out of shape
should be grounds for divorce oh wait
Pearl please please ask the ladies when
women want to degrade each other what is
the first thing they attack looks or
body count status possessions black is
Panther you have 304 friends who don't
think strippers or 304s you think women
should do whatever they feel like you're
not a virgin you're not traditional
black is Panther love is a choice you
have to choose someone every day only
children and animals deserves love
animals adults deserve nothing they
haven't earned oh hey
why is it that when a woman wants to
degrade other women they go for looks
money status weight husband but ho comes
first Manny F do you think your parents
or mother prepare you for marriage Joe
Seraph here's for the Uber Uber so the
red multi-millionaire Griff
uh oh goes already sorry
um Eric Powell Pearl you're doing God's
work a scout and Bradley I've been rich
or I've been poor I'm rich now but I can
lose it just as fast as I made it Kate
can solidine Pearl if you do yoga daily
workouts I will join
ah
um EIP Doug lion just how men just how
some men need to work the coal mines
some women need to work the street we
think you have a service to Queen
ambitious you have to become Elon Musk
to Queen Hilton
my name is pronounced uh takim Pearl LOL
sorry look at zakim
um black is Panther uh fetish is not a
wife a man smashes a whale but gives but
give him a Lambo and a million bucks
he's with models every day and I think
that's everything but I'm gonna refresh
it really quick also guys we're actually
talking we have blessing
what was your idea of blessing for the
workouts and ask them where we should
put it tell them your idea you guys do
you want to see pale do morning workouts
in the gym every day on the main Channel
or should we make a new channel for it
and we're gonna bring girls as well to
it I think it should be stuff for staff
old stuff I was thinking that too
actually I think it should be a star
thing I'll be behind the camera store no
I I think that as I'm the disabled when
I show her the camera will you be there
Auntie every time oh yeah five days a
week I will come down just to watch
she's a lot so far and you've proved
yourself that you you can hold yourself
yeah yeah you should be here every day
yeah so but who would hold the camera I
will I'm coming to hold the camera we
could have we could have King do it no
he's fit I'm coming to hold the camera
I'm saying he doesn't need to work out
he could he could and I do
[Laughter]
the people like seeing you on camera
I think there's a lot of people that
want to see what you look like blessing
yeah he's out there I don't know about
that is that there I realized it was out
there the other day but I'm not saying
we're
but he's out there
yeah
have there been any super chats while I
was reading it's making me verify with
my login it's just being weird yeah
there was a few more
hold on let me see if I can
I can do it
I need to um
I need a little mini studio at home
then I can just do my own thing
that's it you need oh a mini studio at
home yeah work it out guys Super Truck
for aunties yeah then I can work out oh
a minute so if you're coming out the
house yeah I got a shoe lit how far away
do you live from here
a two and a half hours drive 100 and odd
miles yeah she comes two and a half
hours so if you guys want to see a six
hour five hour round trip if you want to
see anti-stream at home okay I just
logged in again and we need to see more
of you guys on Andy's on this live
stream on Mondays thank you yeah Auntie
what time are her live streams Monday we
are live 3 30 GMT on Monday yeah I'm
having the vegan the vegetarian and the
Carnival
or having discussions
on Monday
blessing there's no new super chats I
just refreshed it oh
guys faith in you guys so that's what
we're doing he he's gaslighting me again
always gaslighting
I had faith in these guys yeah but
actually guys
um auntie
yeah we're gonna we're gonna try to get
her a home studio so she doesn't have to
come here all the time yes okay I know
that's what they've given me that's why
they changed my Monday time so I can get
home before dark
okay
um guys a couple announcements before we
end the show um first we have two clips
channels just pearly clips and pearl
daily make sure you go subscribe to both
um also four membership tiers first tier
gets you to be a part of the live chat
in the beginning of the show second is
Discord behind the scenes Vlogs third is
connect on social media and four is a
one-on-one call also guys blessing do
you think we could get I want to get
like the top Super chatter like they're
they get a message somehow that they can
show the next show we should do that
yeah yeah
like a sign or something I don't know
I'll get them on the screen on the
screen okay
um IG just pearly thinks one um send me
show ideas show topics videos you want
me to react to
um Rumble guys
sorry I can't talk guys Nick Fuentes was
so funny on the freaking
um panel that he was literally so funny
so you guys really should watch that we
also had Sterling Cooper on one of the
episodes so make sure you go watch that
that's on Rumble full episodes wife
school
um I don't know when they're gonna put
it out but make sure you're subscribed
because you're gonna see me learn how to
knead bread and you all know how to
knead bread
yeah I do
you call me wifey
um okay uh animation Channel just pearly
animations
um also all super chats I'm gonna read
after final thoughts so if you have any
you know speak your piece
anything you really want to say before
the end of the show I'm gonna let them
do final thoughts send the super chats
now and I'll read them okay starting
here any final thoughts any social media
you want to plug speak now or forever
hold your peace
no I think I'm good I'm good thank you
I'm all good you're good
um just be authentic guys that's all you
have really
um and my Instagram is star McKenzie
underscore follow me I follow you black
it's all love baby
I don't see Jenny Auntie Jenner
Instagram
um I'll teach any YouTube
I don't really follow no one so people
ask me to follow can you please follow
me then I'll follow you but I don't
really follow no one because I'm not
really into it and um
yeah that's it in it and then Jenny
Auntie Jenny UK on Tick Tock it's just
food
but yeah that's about it oh can I just
say one thing there's an author I'm
looking for he wrote a book for his son
I'm trying to find him
because I've got a show coming up with
authors so he was supposed to come
before all I remember that he's a social
worker
so he needs to get contact me because I
need you to come back on because he
tried to come on One show but he got
called out on an emergency so
yeah
also guys guys if anyone wants to do if
anyone has an X
that they want to rekindle with okay any
of y'all especially the women out there
do you even ask that you did wrong
okay do you have someone that maybe
you're thinking about getting back
together with you're not sure if you can
work it out sign up for therapy with
Auntie Jenny or she will analyze your
relationship and decide help you decide
is this a good fit or should you guys be
apart forever well Zappos welcome DM me
on Instagram just pearly things one you
know let me let me know if you wanna do
that oh is that why you got that that
room all set up
no that's the one-on-one interview room
so if people want to do interviews but
they also will do therapy with you it
looks like a therapy room yeah so you
can you know therapy I've done it before
I've got my certificate but instead of
you guys laying down aunties and he's
gonna be laying down yeah I think I need
it after hearing the stories out there
yeah yeah
um Auntie Jenny's offering therapy or
couples counseling either or as you know
I've been doing that on IG
yeah
so yeah I've been doing don't tell them
that because we need them to come on the
show so no those are the end UK one
those are the the US ones they call me
up but the UK ones come down
okay
um make bread is a fun relaxing hitting
as a stress relief um Jesus a shout out
to Booboo I got my wife to start
watching
yeah okay that's all the super chats
thank you guys so much for watching the
show I think we got up to like 4 000
live viewers we really want to get to
10K live viewers this year that is our
goal so make sure you guys tune in on
Thursdays and Saturdays
um we're gonna shoot to start at 8 30.
that's our goal this year so hopefully
we can get into that
um also
yeah let me know in the comments where
you want to do the workout Channel you
know this channel different we're
thinking a different Channel but we
don't really know we're gonna have um
Auntie Jenny and um King Richie's do
different workouts too so it'll be fun
like the video on your way out subscribe
to the channel follow my Instagram and
I'll talk to you guys next time bye I
foreign